20h36 nous sommes en direct et c'est un
événement comme tous les 5 ans
finalement un moment majeur de
l'histoire de la politique française
dans à peu près 25 minutes Emmanuel
Macron et Marine Le Pen seront face à
face pour le 8e débat d'entre deux tours
de la 5e République vous pourrez le
suivre en direct sur Le Figaro.fr sur
Youtube et pour vous accompagner
jusqu'au début de ce duel je suis avec
Sarah le coeur bonsoir Sarah comment ça
va ça va bien et vous Thibault vous êtes
excité vous êtes impatiente oui moi je
suis impatiente de découvrir ça c'est
comme un match de boxe et on a hâte de
voir les deux les deux athlètes du jour
vous pouvez donc réagir sur le Figaro.fr
sur le chat sur Youtube aussi là vous
réponds elle sait tout des coulisses des
préparatifs de ce débat je vous pose la
première question
donnez-moi tous les facteurs je veux du
factuel dites moi combien de temps ça va
durer les débats qu'on va avoir je veux
tout savoir dites moi alors le débat va
durer deux heures et demie enfin si tout
va bien ça peut ça peut aller jusqu'à
trois heures il se laisse la possibilité
de déborder une seigneur de plus et il y
aura huit thèmes abordés vous savez
c'est très c'est très négocié ça en
amont l'ordre de passage des thèmes
du tout et alors normalement les
candidats doivent se mettre d'accord sur
le premier thème à aborder sauf que là
cette fois-ci ne se sont pas mis
d'accord par contre c'est quand les
chaînes ont dû procéder à un tirage au
sort et c'est le pouvoir d'achat qui a
été tiré au sort donc les deux candidats
vont démarrer sur le pouvoir d'achat
ensuite il y aura le modèle social et
puis très vite on parlera
d'environnement de il y a quelques
années il y a 5 ans et bien ça
avait été frappé comme on dit dans le
métier et ça a fait des bas ça a été
l'objet de contestation je l'ai là le
programme très précis pouvoir d'achat
international modèle social
environnement économie avec la
compétitivité l'attractivité la jeunesse
sécurité immigration et puis on
terminera par les institutions et vous
l'avez dit le premier des débat il est
important parce que c'est
le moment le plus regardé finalement
c'est là où il y a le plus de monde à
21h entre 21h et 21h30 c'est là où il y
a 20 millions de téléspectateurs puisque
il y a 5 ans il y avait une moyenne de
16 millions et demi téléspectateurs
c'est le pire score jamais atteint par
ce débat entre deux tours depuis sa
création en 1974 c'était le plus faible
score donc oui c'était c'était faible
l'année il y a cinq années plus tôt
entre Nicolas Sarkozy et François
Hollande ça avait fait 17 millions
17 millions 8 ouais donc ça c'était un
peu un peu mieux et jusqu'à 20 millions
c'était en 2007 entre Ségolène Royal et
Nicolas Sarkozy alors les records
1980 30 millions de personnes à l'époque
c'est une autre époque on peut comparer
il y avait pas autant de chaînes est-ce
que c'est
oui déjà c'était sur qu'une chaîne
l'ORTF à l'époque 74 c'est le tout
premier débat animé par Alain Duhamel
notamment et entre Valéry Giscard
d'Estaing et
il y avait 25 millions et jusqu'à 30
millions en 1980 et oui il y avait pas
autant de chaînes là on a des chaînes de
la TNT enfin l'audience
vous répondez vous posez vos questions
et puis on vous répond aux questions
toutes simples de péridot péri sur
YouTube à quelle heure commence le débat
c'est à 21h 21h pétantes voilà alors
tout ça c'est négocié il faut bien
comprendre je veux vous expliquer ça ça
comment ça se passe ça va dans le détail
qui finit par trancher comment on gère
ça c'est les chaînes c'est j'imagine que
c'est très tendu cette discussion avant
là alors tout est négocié de la
température du plateau ouais jusqu'au
position alors je peux vous dire la
température du plateau pour ce soir ce
sera 19 degrés
ce qui est assez frais parce que quand
on reste deux heures et demie trois
heures assis à une table à discuter à ne
rien faire quasiment enfin à ne pas
bouger c'est assez frais et d'ailleurs
pour l'anecdote en 2012 c'était Laurence
Ferrari et David qui arbitraille débat
et c'était la même température que ce
soir 19 degrés et bien les deux arbitres
de la soirée avaient demandé un
radiateur à leurs pieds pour se chauffer
parce que vraiment il se cachait tout
simplement sur le plateau et en fait
l'idée pourquoi il fait frais comme ça
sur sur ce plateau du débat d'entre-deux
tours parce que les les
candidats ne veulent pas transpirer on
peut vraiment perdre parce que une
question il y a pas de pub ce soir il y
a pas de pub donc il n'y a aucun raccord
maquillage possible donc l'idée c'est de
rester le plus le plus frais possible
pendant deux heures et demie jusqu'à
trois heures donc c'est l'idée c'est
qu'il fasse frais sur le plateau et en
2007 d'ailleurs c'est assez drôle c'est
Ségolène Royal elle voulait elle avait
demandé 22 degrés
tandis que Nicolas Sarkozy vous voulait
une température un peu plus fraîche à 18
19 pour juste et en fait elle elle
voulait 22 pourquoi pour faire
transpirer son adversaire et qui perd un
peu ses moyens c'est malin on comprend
la subtilité de
de ce débat en fait c'est un show c'est
réalisé comme comme un match de foot là
c'est oui alors c'est même le
réalisateur et dites-moi le réalisateur
c'est pas anodin c'est pas un
réalisateur qui a l'habitude de faire de
la politique non c'est un réalisateur
qui réalise les émissions de
divertissement mais d'ailleurs comme
celui d'il y a 5 ans là alors cette
année
qui réalise il y a 5 ans c'était Tristan
Carné et en fait c'est Marine Le Pen qui
a demandé à changer de réalisateur ce
qu'elle n'avait pas été satisfaite il y
a 5 ans des plans de coupe on va
sûrement en parler parce que les plans
de coupe évidemment c'est négocié aussi
et il y a 5 ans elle avait été
mécontente des plans de coupe alors
justement expliquez-moi ce que c'est
déjà un plan de coupe simplement on peut
montrer peut-être vous êtes en train de
parler c'est vous qui êtes en train de
parler je vous écoute voilà alors un
plan de coupe c'est par exemple je parle
et vous on va vous filmer pendant que je
parle pour voir votre réaction donc par
exemple si je suis en train de boire ça
s'appelait pas Marine Le Pen voilà
vous fouillez dans vos notes vos fiches
de manière un peu perdue ça peut on peut
perdre un peu de prestance sur le
plateau et c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'elle a
reproché au réalisateurs Tristan carnier
il y a 5 ans c'est qu'à un moment donné
il y a un plan de coupe pendant que
Emmanuel Macron parle elle cherche dans
ses fiches et elle a l'air vraiment
quasiment dépassée et ça ça lui a pas
plu et c'est pour ça qu'elle a demandé
un changement de réalisateur donc c'est
Didier froly qui réalise et les plantes
coupes cette année alors il y en aura
mais ils seront fait de manière un peu
plus par simonieuse c'est à dire que on
ne pourra pas le réalisateur ne pourra
pas montrer à l'écran des plans de coupe
justement quand vous buvez un verre
d'eau quand vous vous grattez le nez ça
ce sera interdit contrairement à lire 5
ans donc les plans de coupe ce sera
juste quand vous me regardez voilà tel
que vous êtes là je vous écoute vous me
concentrez vous me regardez là vous
pouvez être filmé en plan de coupe si
vous faites autre chose c'est impossible
alors j'ai vu que chaque camp avait
désigné euh un conseiller réalisateur
qui sera en régie alors comment ça
marche qu'est-ce qui va se passer
qu'est-ce qui peut dire un réalisateur
mais ce réalisateur donc Didier froly ce
soir est entouré par deux personnes de
quoi réalisateur si on peut dire d'un
côté le
coréalisateur
d'Emmanuel Macron et de l'autre celui de
Marine Le Pen qui vérifie tout et qui
qui joue un peu aux inspecteurs sachez
que c'est Philippe Balard l'ancien
journaliste il sera le donc le
conseiller réalisateur pour Marine Le
Pen et puis c'est Jérôme revont grand
réalisateur qui a réalisé d'ailleurs les
meeting d'Emmanuel Macron à Nanterre et
à Marseille qui qui sera lui le
conseiller donc réalisateur en régie
derrière Didier frolic faut le dire
réalisé Danse avec les stars par exemple
beaucoup de caméra j'ai vu 20 16 caméras
cette caméra plus faut rajouter à cela
des travellings et une grue donc c'est
des gros moyens il faut savoir que sur
le plateau un peu comme nous ici ils
sont seulement quatre les deux arbitres
et les candidats et sinon tout est
automatique un peu comme ici vous
continuez à nous poser vos questions
vous avez vu Sarah le café avec moi à
tout compris elle sait tout de de des
enjeux en tout cas technique et au-delà
de la politique c'est on a bien compris
que il y a une question d'image avant
tout dans dans ce débat est-ce que c'est
intéressant toujours les gens alors les
audiences on a vu sont un peu en baisse
parce que les gens sont devant leur télé
ce soir à se dire il faut que je regarde
à tout prix au début oui ils peuvent ils
peuvent partir en cours d'émission mais
vous savez
les journalistes politiques d'ailleurs
sont partagés sur
l'importance de ce débat entre deux
tours on dit souvent de toute manière le
c'est l'élection est déjà faite c'est
pas là que les Français vont faire leur
choix pour pour leur vote de dimanche
d'ailleurs il y a jamais eu vraiment de
surprise un vote n'a jamais manipuler
alors on dit seulement quand même qu'il
y a 5 ans que c'était écarté
complètement entre entre
deux et les spécialistes politiques sont
nombreux à dire que Marine Le Pen a
perdu aussi l'élection définitivement à
cause de
sa sortie quand elle a un peu divagué
sur ses potentiels
et elle le dit et c'est intéressant elle
s'est préparée Marine Le Pen et elle dit
qu'elle n'a jamais revu ce débat c'est
dire le traumatisme elle s'est préparé
pendant plusieurs jours elle s'est mis à
l'écart pendant près de deux jours en
Normandie avec des conseillers qui
étaient d'ailleurs des conseillers des
hauts fonctionnaires des personnes de
l'administration qui ont le profil
sociologique et l'âge de Macron c'est
vous dire pour vraiment s'impliquer
complètement mais c'est vrai un inscrit
sur trois à regarder le dernier débat et
souvent les gens qui regardent ce débat
ce sont des gens qui savent probablement
pour qu'ils vont voter des habitués de
la politique
on regarde ce débat ensemble sur le
Figaro live à 21h évidemment on aura un
débrief derrière avec Vincent roux et
toutes les équipes du Figaro donc allez
13 14 minutes avant le début de ce débat
vous continuez à réagir et on vous
répond je voulais vous poser une
question à propos des journalistes alors
les journalistes ce soir c'est Gilles
Bouleau c'est pas anodin non plus alors
Gilles Bouleau pour TF1 faut le préciser
et les Salamé pour France 2 un
représentant de chaque chaîne qui
organise ce débat c'est pas anodin alors
il faut expliquer quand même au
téléspectateurs que c'est un duo qui a
été proposé par les chaînes et c'est les
candidats qui acceptent ou non les
candidats il faut le savoir ils ont le
droit de récuser des noms mais ils ont
le droit ils ont pas le droit de récuser
50 noms c'est-à-dire qu'ils peuvent
accuser un nom cette année c'était
apparemment Anne-Sophie Lapix par le
camp de Marine Le Pen Emmanuel Macron a
assuré qu'il avait récusé personne et il
y a 5 ans c'est Anne-Claire Coudray qui
a été récusé toujours par Marine Le Pen
pourtant ces journalistes est-ce qu'ils
ont une importance capitale est-ce
qu'ils vont vraiment intervenir ce soir
et non parce que leur rôle c'est
vraiment le mode mineur du journalisme
pour en avoir interrogé quelques-uns des
anciens ils me disent vraiment on sert
de pas se plat on est même des
speakerines
[Musique]
quand on est journaliste politique
présentateur du 20 heures de TF1
notamment non ils sont là pour
surveiller le temps de parole
à surveiller aussi l'ordre des
thématiques à lancer des sujets voilà à
quoi il servent même la première
question chaque mot compte dans dans la
formulation des questions donc ils sont
vraiment c'est des faire valoir et c'est
vraiment un travail de sobriété et
d'humilité ils doivent se mettre en
retrait la réaction d'Aurélie gaillard
sur Youtube qui nous dit la stratégie de
chacun c'est d'accuser l'autre d'accuser
l'autre et c'est peut-être ça aussi le
rôle des journalistes qui seront plus
des médiateurs c'est ce qui s'était
passé il y a 5 ans et ils l'ont droit à
aucune relance les relances sont c'est
en fait ils doivent laisser les
candidats eux se contredire ce n'est pas
à eux d'intervenir en disant ah mais non
mais vous n'aviez pas dit ça il y a je
sais pas deux ans ils n'ont pas le droit
d'intervenir c'est c'est au candidat qui
s'affrontent qui doivent se contredire
et et vraiment être dans le combat de
boxe eux ils sont juste là pour dire
mais il vous reste 20 secondes vous avez
deux minutes d'avance sur sur monsieur
Macron ou sur Madame Le Pen enfin voilà
alors le temps de parole justement ça
aussi c'est extrêmement regardé j'ai vu
que sur le plateau le temps était bien
précis que ils auront devant eux un
écran qui dit sur chaque thème s'ils ont
parlé le même temps on est à ce point de
détail là c'est très important ah mais
tout est tout est négocié donc je vous
dis de la température
jusque au placement même qui démarre et
qui et qui finit ça c'est tiré au sort
donc Marine Le Pen a gagné oui et c'est
Marine Le Pen qui a gagné ça c'est
important c'est déjà une victoire non
c'est peut-être le mot est fort mais
c'est quand même pour un camp pour un
staff d'un candidat ça c'est une oui une
petite victoire parce que elle avait
déjà commencé il y a 5 ans elle
terminera ce soir et également et puis
il y a 5 ans on se souvient qu'elle
avait tout de suite attaqué Emmanuel
Macron et qu'elle avait donné le ton ça
peut donner ça peut donner une tendance
est-ce qu'on sait qu'elle est alors
au-delà de du fond sur la forme
qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent faire on dit
qu'il voudrait s'inspirer de ce débat de
1995 qui était un débat un peu ennuyeux
un peu tombé dans l'oubli mais calme et
dont tout le monde s'accorde à dire
qu'il était très bon sur le fond
honnêtement les les journalistes
politiques craignent que le débat soit
très technique et qui est pas beaucoup
d'envolée lyrique comme on les aime
finalement dans les débats d'entre nous
parce que ce qu'on attend c'est un
dérapage c'est les petites phrases aussi
qui restent on pense notamment à vous
n'avez pas le monopole du cœur c'était
cette phrase de Valéry Giscard d'Estaing
lancé à François Mitterrand en 7 voilà
où vous n'êtes pas le Président je suis
le candidat entre
avec Mitterrand on se souvient de toutes
ces phrases et c'est très important
l'anaphore de François Hollande ça
c'était en 2012 et puis Marine Le Pen
qui perd pied il y a 5 ans pendant son
débat enfin voilà il y a chaque fois un
moment fort dans le débat et c'est ça
qu'on attend aussi en direct et c'est
pour ça que beaucoup de gens regardent
les jeunes ont du mal à être convaincus
par la politique assis intéressée je
vois un commentaire sur Le Figaro.fr de
Christian ce soir les jeunes ont besoin
d'être convaincus de mes oublions pas
alors je rappelle que la jeunesse sera
un thème qui arrivera d'ailleurs assez
tard donc pour les
collégiens et lycéens bon c'est pas
forcément la meilleure option mais
peut-être le l'idée de faire un show à
l'américaine d'avoir quelque chose on a
vu un les candidats arrivés sur un tapis
rouge ils sont d'ailleurs en ce moment
dans les locaux de la salle à plein de
souvenirs du lundi et pour l'anecdote où
se tourne The Voice
et en ce moment même cet après-midi
c'est Camille Combal qui tournait une sa
nouvelle émission adaptée d'un format de
Jimmy Fallon aux États-Unis et qui a
croisé donc les candidats enfin les
arbitres tout du moins Gilles Bouleau il
est à Salamé ils se sont croisés voilà
dans les donc on voit un peu le mélange
des gens dans ce dans ce dans ce débat
vous avez parlé avec les modérateurs
présentateurs de diacon oui Nathalie
saint-cric et Christophe jacquub
quelle est leur retour d'expérience
rappelez que déjà je savais pas été
forcément le premier choix oui alors
c'est des choix d'ailleurs il le
reconnaissent eux-mêmes ils ont été ils
ont été là parce que il y a pas eu de
terrain d'entente entre les deux
candidats sur les arbitres à l'époque
pour pour la faire courte au départ ça
devait être les deux présentateurs du
20h de l'époque à la fois sur TF1 donc
Gilles Bouleau et David Pujadas pour
France 2 sauf que l'équipe d'Emmanuel
Macron a dit Amazon ces deux hommes donc
on voudrait la parité donc là TF1
propose à une claire coudra à la place
de Gilles Bouleau mais Marine Le Pen met
son veto sur Anne-Claire Coudray du coup
problème et par conséquent comme il n'y
a pas eu de compromis entre les deux
candidats et bien
tF1 et France dons préférés proposer
leur chef de service politique
respectifs à savoir Christophe jacqbyzin
pour la une et Nathalie singré pour la 2
alors je vous relance sur Nathalie
Saintry qui a écrit sale jacuzine je
vois ce commentaire de Mika sur Youtube
qui nous dit j'ai pas le coeur de
regarder un débat de petite phrase la
politique c'est du sérieux on aura le
droit à une dispute ridicule ça c'est un
vrai problème il s'était beaucoup
interpellé il y a 5 ans et ça avait été
compliqué
parfois puis les Nathalie saint-cric et
Christophe jacuzine avait du mal à
intervenir mais il faut savoir que leur
micro est baissé pendant les
interventions des candidats c'est à dire
que c'est pour ça on ne les entendait
mal et ils ont été beaucoup critiqués
pour ça d'ailleurs mais à tort parce que
malheureusement ils sont impuissants
face à ça leur micro est coupé enfin
voir couper en fait presque
d'arrêter les candidats on les entend
pas les entends pas et sur le plateau
les candidats et c'est ce que m'a dit
Nathalie saint-cric que j'ai eu la
semaine dernière
tu n'es pas les candidats même avant
c'est-à-dire que quand ils arrivent sur
le plateau il y a une photo qui est
prise entre les quatre protagonistes de
la soirée donc les deux arbitres et les
deux candidats photos presque
historiques
pour les journalistes c'est presque ça
qui est important d'être sur cette photo
puis même à l'image vous rentrez à Lina
ça c'est ce que Guillaume Durand avait
dit à Christophe jacubizin la veille du
débat il lui a dit voilà tu seras
critiqué mais toi au moins tu rentreras
à Lina donc voilà et donc après cette
photo il s'installe et là c'est le
silence le plus total le silence de mort
que les journalistes tenteront souvent
en lançant une banalité
Christophe jacubizin avait dit vous
aimez ce décor couleur champagne et là
aucun des deux ne répond ni Emmanuel
Macron ni Marine Le Pen et là c'est
c'est le moment de solitude pour les
journalistes les normes tensions la
pression sur les deux candidats qui
doivent être en place début le débat
dans 5 minutes 30 21h tapantes vous le
suivez sur le Figaro live on aura un
débrief ensuite en fin de en fin de
débat pour analyser les performances de
chacun alors il y a des chiffres on a
dit 19 degrés sur le plateau 16 caméras
il y a un espace j'allais vous envoyer
ça c'est important
cette fois oui alors déjà la distance
entre les candidats ils auront 2 mètres
50 ils seront face à face et 2m50 les
séparons et ils auront une table séparée
chacun parce qu'avant ils étaient sur
une grande et même table comme celle-ci
et là ils auront un pupitre si on peut
dire chacun et face à face à deux
médecins et ils sont assis et quant aux
journalistes et bien eux et ça c'est une
première depuis la création du débat
d'entre-deux tours en 74 et bien il se
ils feront table à part tout simplement
on ne les verra même pas sur le plan là
enfin si on les verra de dos mais on ne
les verra pas de face comme on avait pu
les voir les années précédentes en fait
finalement pas à l'image oui non enfin
ils pourront sur un plan large ils
seront probablement de dos mais non et
en fait ils veulent vraiment se mettre
en retrait pour accentuer véritablement
le rôle ce que je vous disais
précédemment je vois aussi que l'écran
géant haute résolution qui servira
derrière plan mesure 30 mètres de large
pour 3,7 m de haut voilà ça vous donne
l'idée l'idée générale de ce grand show
que que les Français vont vivre ce soir
sans parler du fond sur la forme comment
se prépare les candidats il y a une peur
de la fatigue j'imagine c'est long un
des émissions comme ça en direct et il
faut arriver en forme c'est pour ça que
souvent les candidats là vous voyez on
est mercredi on est en milieu de semaine
et bien souvent en début de semaine ils
ne prévoit rien il vit de leur agenda
c'est le cas d'ailleurs on n'a pas vu
Emmanuel Macron je crois depuis lundi
soir et Emmanuel et Marine Le Pen on n'a
pas vu depuis ce weekend donc c'est
vraiment il se prépare comme des comme
des sportifs de haut niveau et ils ont
sûrement des conseillers qui qui des
spin doctor comme on peut les je vais
vous lire ça justement c'est dans le
papier de de ce matin de Arthur Berda et
Charles sapin qui suit Emmanuel Macron
et Charles sapin qui suit Marine Le Pen
euh l'entourage de la candidate a donc
poussé le réalisme jusqu'à choisir pour
Spark partner un Horace ces fameux haut
fonctionnaires et intellectuel qui
conseille la candidate et la preuve en
fiche de la sociologie et de l'âge de
Macron c'est ce que je vous disais et un
conseiller qui rapporte que là c'est une
préparation psychologique presque une
préparation à caractère sportif on sait
que Marine Le Pen c'est manqué il y a 5
ans on est vraiment là dans un événement
quel quel
il y a 5 ans aussi à l'image quelque
chose qui ce qui a frappé aussi les
journalistes Nathalie saint cric
notamment c'est qu'elle était arrivée
avec un dossier épais comme ça avec des
notes et d'ailleurs on le voyait je vous
en parler sur les plans de coupe tout à
l'heure elle farfouillait dans son
dossier donc épais comme ça avec du
stabilo partout un peu le bazar on peut
le dire tandis que Emmanuel Macron était
arrivé avec des fiches A4 seulement 20
lignes d'écriture de notes et voilà déjà
ça contrastait et aimer mine de rien
d'arriver avec un dossier avec enfin
avec 30 cm d'épaisseur
on peut déjà prendre le dessus sur son
adversaire ou pas dans deux minutes et
10 secondes le grand débat d'entre deux
tours de la présidentielle avec donc 8
grands thèmes abordés de 20 minutes
chacun c'est ça tirage au sort des
sujets tirage au sort sur tout un tirage
au sort même sur les loges on a appris
sur les loges sur la visite aussi parce
que les équipes le staff de chaque
candidat visite le plateau avant
l'arrivée de leur poulain donc Marine Le
Pen en premier lieu a ensuite marine
Emmanuel Macron sans se croiser bien sûr
il ne se croiseront que 10 minutes avant
le direct ils doivent être en place
rendez-vous dans une minute trente tout
à l'heure après le après le débat et
bien vous retrouver Vincent roux ses
invités les spécialistes du Figaro qui
seront là pour analyser ce duel ou avec
Sarah cœur ce qu'on a essayé de vous
expliquer c'est la forme de ce grand
débat qui est toujours un moment
historique je vous rappelle que 8 grands
thèmes donc seront abordés dans l'ordre
le pouvoir d'achat c'est le thème par
lequel vous voulez commencer Marine Le
Pen on se souvient qu'il y a 5 ans elle
avait commencé le premier thème c'était
l'emploi face au ministre de l'Économie
sortant c'était peut-être un petit peu
compliqué donc pouvoir d'achat en
premier thème international modèle
social environnement économie avec la
compétitivité et l'attractivité
française la jeunesse la sécurité
l'immigration et puis on terminera par
les institutions sachez que Marine Le
Pen qui un peu la pression sur ce débat
elle l'a dit à ses équipes le savent
dans une vidéo sur Twitter à 10 avec une
solennité particulière que j'aborde ce
rendez-vous ah oui mais complètement il
joue leur avenir là clairement parce que
s'il y en a un qui se rate ça peut avoir
une incidence sur le vote de dimanche là
l'écart n'est pas le même que celui d'il
y a 5 ans donc clairement on peut on
peut s'attendre à toute surprise voilà
ce qu'on pouvait dire sur les dessous de
ce débat merci ça a rien de m'avoir
accompagné alors mythique comment 74 ou
en 88 tombé dans l'oubli comment en 95
dans quel case rangera-t-on ce débat on
verra ça dans deux heures Marine Le Pen
prendra-t-elle sa revanche Emmanuel
Macron affirmera-t-il sa position les
réponses c'est tout de suite place à la
politique place à la confrontation
d'idées c'est important et vous suivez
ça sur sur figure live à tout à l'heure
merci beaucoup
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous pour ce
grand débat du second tour de l'élection
présidentielle moment très attendue de
la vie démocratique de notre pays
bonsoir Gilles bonsoir Léa bonsoir à
tous bonsoir Marine Le Pen bonsoir
bonsoir Emmanuel Macron bonsoir vous
avez deux heures trente ce soir pour
exposer votre projet votre vision de la
France ceux qui vous séparent mais aussi
votre personnalité alors les règles du
jeu nous sommes là avec Gilles Bouleau
pour faire respecter la stricte égalité
de vos temps de parole et les
chronomètres que vous voyez à l'écran
seront foi nous sommes aussi là pour
faire respecter l'impartialité la clarté
la bonne tenue des échanges précisons
aussi que vous êtes chacun responsable
de vos propos des chiffres des faits des
dates que vous donnerez ce soir votre
adversaire aura bien sûr la possibilité
de les contester allons nous évoquerons
la place de la France en Europe et dans
le monde alors que la guerre en Ukraine
fait rage nous parlerons aussi de
l'environnement un sujet très attendu
notamment par les jeunes qui nous
regardent ce soir mais aussi la santé
l'hôpital les retraites l'attractivité
de la France la sécurité l'éducation
l'immigration nous vous demanderons
aussi quel président ou quel présidente
vous serez et comment vous exercerez le
pouvoir et nous commencerons par la
préoccupation numéro 1 des Français
depuis des mois le pouvoir d'achat c'est
parti on y va Marine Le Pen c'est vous
qui avez été tiré au sort pour prendre
la parole en premier
[Musique]
tu es dans le monde mais le plus grand
atout de la France c'est son peuple
Marine Le Pen oserais-je alors que le
débat à peine commencé vous interrompre
juste pour vous rappelez que nous
voulions avec là vous posez un un à
l'autre dans les mêmes termes pour une
durée d'une minute trente la question
suivante ce qui nous empêchera
évidemment pas de vous exprimer vous
avez donc une minute 30 l'un et l'autre
et vous donc d'abord Marine Le Pen en
quoi seriez-vous une meilleure
présidente que votre adversaire Emmanuel
Macron je vais démarrer avant même que
la musique vous pouvez reprendre ce
crédit
les secondes j'en suis absolument en
avril j'en étais à dire que le plus
grand atout de la France et son peuple
un peuple volontaire un peuple solidaire
un peuple créatif notre peuple je le
connais bien je ça fait des années que
je vais à sa rencontre je suis obligé
d'être témoin que depuis cinq ans je
l'ai vu souffrir je l'ai vu s'inquiéter
je l'ai vu s'inquiéter d'un déclassement
d'une sorte de de précarité qu'il
ressent généralisée et puis je l'ai vu
s'inquiéter aussi de l'avenir et douté
je voudrais lui dire que un autre choix
est possible fondé sur le respect fondé
sur le bon sens
si le peuple français me fait l'honneur
de m'apporter sa confiance dimanche
prochain je serai la présidente du
régalien c'est-à-dire de la Renaissance
démocratique des protections collectives
de la liberté de la souveraineté et puis
de sa sécurité je serais aussi la
présidente du quotidien de la valeur
travail du pouvoir d'achat de l'école
creusait du savoir de la santé partout
pour tous de l'assimilation
mais aussi de la promotion sociale mais
surtout je serai la présidente de la
Concorde restaurée entre les Français je
serai la présidente de la justice je
serai la présidente de la fraternité
nationale je serai la présidente de la
pêche civile la fraternité nationale
c'est celle qui unit les Français et qui
est autour d'un projet collectif leur
permet de se projeter ensemble dans
l'avenir merci Marine Le Pen même
question pour vous Emmanuel Macron vous
avez une minute trente également si vous
êtes réélu en quoi serez-vous un
meilleur président que votre adversaire
bonsoir à tous les deux bonsoir madame
Le Pen et bonsoir à nos compatriotes qui
nous qui nous écoutent ce soir et je
pense que c'est un moment important
parce que c'est celui qui permet aussi
la clarification sur nos projets qui
permet de trancher dans quelques jours
nous avons tous ensemble traversé vous
venez de le rappeler madame une période
si difficile
des cris sans précédent une pandémie
comme nous n'avions pas connu depuis un
siècle et aujourd'hui le retour de la
guerre sur le sol européen
et donc d'évidence nous parlons d'une
époque où les peurs les inquiétudes sont
là
et donc j'ai traversé à la tête de notre
pays par la confiance donnée cette
période en essayant de prendre les
bonnes décisions
et je veux continuer de le faire parce
que je crois d'abord que nous devons et
nous pouvons rendre notre pays plus
indépendant et plus fort par son
économie par le travail par la recherche
l'innovation par sa culture je pense
aussi que nous pouvons et nous devons
améliorer les vies du quotidien par
l’exhi immense chantier que sont celui
de l'école de la santé pour ne citer que
et de nos enfants au grand âge nous y
reviendrons dans le débat de permettre
de rendre cette vie meilleure puis je
crois que notre France
sera plus forte si elle sait se saisir
de la question écologique vous l'évoquez
à un instant et devenir une grande
puissance écologique du 21e siècle et
c'est rendre l'Europe plus forte nous
l'avons fait ces dernières années et
c'est au combien important dans le
moment que nous vivons voilà les
quelques mots qui me paraissent
importants et en tout cas ce qui guidera
mes choix dans les années à venir si les
Françaises et les Français me font
confiance et bien on va commencer si
vous le voulez bien l'un et l'autre par
le premier thème de ce débat c'est donc
le pouvoir d'achat les prix ne cessent
d'augmenter et encore plus depuis le
début de la guerre en Ukraine les
Français le ressentent tous les jours au
moment de payer leurs courses au moment
au moment de mettre de l'essence dans
leur voiture ou de régler la facture du
chauffage Marine Le Pen vous avez la
parole en premier avec une inflation qui
risque de s'installer dans la durée
qu'allez-vous faire concrètement pour
aider les Français d'abord je suis
obligé là encore d'être le porte-parole
des Français parce que Monsieur Macron
je vous ai entendu avec votre
gouvernement vous réjouir d'avoir
augmenté le pouvoir d'achat des Français
moi je n'ai vu que des Français qui
m'ont parlé du problème de pouvoir
d'achat je n'ai vu que des Français me
dire qu'il n'y arrivait plus qu'ils ne
s'en sortait plus qu'il n'arrivait plus
à boucler les fins de moi et cette
française sur 10 considère que ils ont
perdu du pouvoir d'achat depuis 5 ans
alors vous avez fait des choix vous avez
fait le choix de mettre en place la taxe
carbone qui aggravait le prix de
l'essence
vous avez fait le choix de baisser des
aides qui étaient essentielles pour un
certain nombre de nos compatriotes
notamment l'aide de logement de 5 euros
et moi je veux véritablement faire du
pouvoir d'achat de la priorité de mon
prochain quinquennat chez les Français
me font confiance
par l'intermédiaire de trois leviers
d'abord baisser les dépenses contraintes
baisser les dépenses contraintes c'est
baisser aussi la fiscalité je veux
proposer de baisser de manière pérenne
pas d'échec pas des tickets de
rationnement
de manière pérenne la TVA sur l'énergie
l'ensemble de l'énergie de 20 à 5,5%
pourquoi parce que je considère que
l'énergie c'est un bien de première
nécessité c'est à dire je veux la
baisser sur le carburant sur le gaz sur
l'électricité sur le fioul c'est 12
milliards que je vais ainsi rendre aux
Français mais je vais aussi leur rendre
du pouvoir d'achat par l'intermédiaire
de baisse de la fiscalité je vais
restituer la demi part fiscale au veuf
et au veuf qui en ont été privés je
souhaite exonérer d'impôt sur le revenu
les moins de 30 ans je souhaite accorder
aux familles une part pleine fiscale dès
le deuxième enfant qui leur permettra de
pouvoir augmenter leur pouvoir d'achat
de 500 euros par an
et puis je veux soutenir la valeur
travail c'est mon deuxième levier la
valeur travail c'est revaloriser un
certain nombre de catégories les
soignants par exemple et les enseignants
qui sont particulièrement maltraités en
dessous de la moyenne européenne mais
c'est aussi
soutenir les apprentis les alternants
les étudiants qui travaillent par des
compléments de revenus de 200 à 300
euros et puis la dernière
le dernier secteur sur lequel je veux
absolument intervenir c'est les
personnes vulnérables parce que j'ai le
sentiment que pendant votre quinquennat
elles ont été particulièrement
maltraités aider les personnes
vulnérables revaloriser la politique à
destination des personnes vulnérables
c'est doubler comme je le souhaite les
aides les allocations pour les familles
monoparentales c'est individualisé et
revaloriser la location adulte
handicapées quand je dis individualiser
c'est la fameuse décongialisation pour
ceux qui connaissent
ce système c'est qu'en réalité vous avez
pris la décision de vous opposer au fait
de pouvoir accorder l'allocation adulte
handicapée quel que soit le revenu du
conjoint en créant en quelque sorte une
dépendance sur une dépendance et puis il
y a le sujet des retraités et
l'indexation des retraites
qui n'a pas été c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire respecter lors des cinq
dernières années voilà
véritablement une priorité absolue des
cinq prochaines années c'est restituer
aux Français leur argent et l'ensemble
de ces mesures permettra de leur rendre
en moyenne 150 à 200 euros par mois et
par foyer bien sûr pour faire cela il
faut faire des choix parce que la
politique c'est l'art des choix et je
fais des choix je fais des choix de
faire des économies sur des dépenses qui
m'apparaissent dispendieuses ou qui
m'apparaissent nocive ou de l'argent qui
en réalité s'enfuit sans que jamais
personne ne s'y soit attaqué de manière
sérieuse
et Marine Le Pen vous avez consacré 4
minutes à cette réponse Emmanuel Macron
je vous pose la même question
qu'allez-vous faire qu'est-ce que vous
engagez à faire pour aider les Français
sur ce point particulier que le pouvoir
d'achat d'abord Madame Le Pen a raison
de dire que les chiffres en effet qui
sont pas les miens qui sont ceux des
organismes indépendants de l'INSEE et
autres établissent très bien que sous ce
quinquennat le pouvoir d'achat en
particulier tous les Français mais des
Françaises et des Français qui
travaillent et qui sont les classes
moyennes et populaires à augmenter mais
les chiffres en moyenne
ne viennent pas aider à finir le moi
quand la vie devient plus chère comme
depuis plusieurs mois et donc c'est une
réalité et je partage totalement ce que
vous avez dit j'ai les mêmes retours de
mes déplacements sur le terrain j'en ai
fait plus de 600 durant les 5 années qui
viennent de s'écouler de colère de
caddie qu'on arrive plus à remplir de
fin de mois difficiles alors d'abord ce
que nous avons fait ce que
j'assume et ce que je veux maintenir
c'est face au prix de l'énergie telle
que Madame Le Pen l'a décrit le bouclier
bouclier ça consistait à bloquer les
prix sur l'électricité et le gaz et
c'est deux fois plus efficace que la
baisse de la TVA et d'ailleurs pour ça
que je me permets de dire que les
Françaises et les Français auront une
augmentation de leur facture de
plusieurs dizaines voire centaines
d'euros par mois si vous deviez être élu
parce que vous avez voté contre ce
bouclier énergétique
et il est évident que quand on bloque
une augmentation qui est de 40 60 100%
pour
certaines énergies on se retrouve avec
des chiffres qui sont problématiques
donc la première chose maintenir ce
bouclier aussi longtemps que la crise
est là et j'assume totalement que c'est
un dispositif de Christ c'est la
différence avec vous la deuxième c'est
que c'est plus efficace deux fois plus
que vous la deuxième différence c'est
qu'en effet ça n'est pas pérenne comme
vous l'avez très bien décrit c'est à
dire que c'est un dispositif de crise
quand on reviendra à des prix
traditionnels j'assume de ne pas
subventionner le gaz et le pétrole qu'on
ne produit pas mais de plutôt dépenser
l'argent public pour aider les ménages à
rénover leur logement ou à changer de
véhicule et sortir des énergies fossiles
comme on a commencé à le faire et c'est
une stratégie sur laquelle je veux
avancer
le deuxième chose c'était le travail moi
je suis fier que tous ensemble nous
ayons permis de créer 1,2 millions de
feuilles de paye
parce que je regardais votre programme
vos 22 mesures il n'y a même pas le mot
chômage dedans ce qui frappant il y a
pas de problème alors je veux c'est une
reconnaissance du travail bien fait pour
les 5 années qui viennent de s'écouler
je vous en remercie mais le meilleur
façon de gagner du pouvoir d'achat c'est
de lutter contre le chômage c'est ce que
nous avons fait en baissant de plus de
deux points de chômage et donc c'est un
million 200000
française et français qui ont retrouvé
un travail je veux qu'on aille plus loin
le SMIC sera augmenté 34 euros par mois
idem pour la plus petite rémunérations
de la fonction publique avant que le
point ne sera repris à l'été les
retraites moyennes seront augmentés
d'environ 60 euros par mois pour une
retraite de 1400 euros ce qui veut dire
une revalorisation délai l'été pourquoi
parce qu'on va pas attendre comme
l'année dernière le premier janvier
prochain et dit puisque là on a une
inflation n’appelait plus de 4%, et puis
pour les plus petites pensions je
souhaite les porter à 1100 euros pour
quelqu'un qui a une carrière complète
contrairement à vous qui les laissait à
1000 euros et pour tous les travailleurs
il y a un point qui me paraît très
important c'est ce que j'appelle le
dividende salarié
c'est que lorsque un patron que ce soit
d'ailleurs une PME TPE ou un très grand
groupe verse du dividende à ses
actionnaires il doit verser ou
l'intéressement participation et nous
simplifierons dès cet été les règles ont
tenues de l'inflation et des problèmes
de pouvoir d'achat pour le libérer et
permettre d'en faire un gain de pouvoir
d'achat ou de la prime pouvoir d'achat
qui sera portée à 6000 euros sans charge
pour l'employeur sans impôt pour le
salarié c'est une prime que nous avons
créé à 3 ans elle était plafonnée à 1000
rapportée à 6000 mais ce sera maintenant
un mécanisme obligatoire qui touchera
tous et toutes et enfin sur les minima
sociaux je souhaite pouvoir les
revaloriser dès cet été en même temps
que de rendre le système beaucoup plus
simple c'est-à-dire de permettre un
système de solidarité à la source ou
toutes celles et ceux qui ont droit les
toucheront manière beaucoup plus simple
ce qui permet à la fois de lutter contre
la fraude et la fraude et le non recours
voilà les premières mesures de pouvoir
d'achat à la fois pour le blocage des
prix plus efficace que la baisse de la
TVA et pour revaloriser le travail d'un
mot sur la location adulte handicapé
elle a été conformément à mes
engagements revalorisé durant ce
quinquennat de 90 euros par mois et je
suis favorable à ce qu'on puisse en
effet corriger cet effet de bord que
vous avez très bien décrit et que quand
une personne qui a la location adulte
handicapée se marie avec quelqu'un qui
beaucoup plus d'argent le père
c'est vrai que le gouvernement n'a pas
soutenu cette mesure vous-même
d'ailleurs vous n'étiez pas là au moment
du débat et donc vous ne vous êtes pas
opposé à celle-ci donc l'un et l'autre
on pourra avancer alors justement Marine
Le Pen on voulait vous faire réagir sur
le SMIC et les salaires parce que vous
avez parlé du travail l'un et l'autre
mais je vois que vous avez envie de
répondre à Emmanuel Macron est-ce que
vous voulez lui répondre j'ai envie de
répondre d'abord pour rappeler mais vous
l'avez dit mais je veux le rappeler que
la mesure de blocage je suis pas du tout
opposé mais moi je suis opposé un
changement de système pérenne
c'est-à-dire je veux sortir du marché
européen de l'électricité qui est en
fait nous oblige à voir les prix de
l'ensemble de l'énergie augmentée dans
des proportions qui sont spectacles
[Musique]
je gèlerai les cotisations patronales
subséquentes et à l'augmentation des
cotisations patronales subséquentes
c'est certes un manque à gagner ça n'est
pas une dépense directe c'est un manque
à gagner je l'admets mais c'est une
dépense pour le budget de l'État Macron
mais les primes dans la vraie vie oui
quand vous allez demander à faire votre
banque on est tous dans la vraie vie
madame dans la vraie vie quand vous
allez chercher après auprès de votre
banque et vous demande votre salaire et
il se moque des primes quand dans la
vraie vie vous allez pour louer un
appartement et bien le propriétaire il
vous demande combien vous gagnez en
salaire il se moque des primes parce
qu'il sait que un coup vous l'aurez la
prime et puis peut-être un coup vous ne
l'aurez pas donc on voit bien que la
mesure que je propose d'augmentation des
revenus et quelque chose qui est capable
d'améliorer la vie quotidienne des
Français
j'enlève j'incite et j'enlève une charge
et les impôts mais ce que je veux dire
par là c'est que j'assume pour le coup
cette mesure et je rentre obligatoire le
mécanisme mais vous n'augmentez pas de
10% les salaires donc aussi vrai
j'assume totalement que la prime a une
part d'aléa qui dépend de l'année vous
avez parfaitement raison mais ce que
vous dites est aussi aléatoire je
voudrais pas que nos compatriotes qui
qui pensent que ce sera de manière sûre
sur leur feuille de paye pense que un
président un président de la République
et puisse décider de ce qui est sur la
feuille de paix
d'une incitation auprès des entreprises
de défiscaliser la prime mais vous
n'allez pas le décider pour l'employeur
oui mais ça va changer leur vie
quotidienne alors que la fenêtre vous
n'allez pas dans leur vie non mais vous
ne faites vous n'allez pas faire les
salaires Madame Le Pen et vous ne ferez
pas non plus les prix monsieur mais
d'ailleurs je ne le dis pas voilà je dis
j'enlève les charges du côté employeur
j'enlève les impôts mais vous essayez de
faire croire que vous vous allez
augmenter les salaires de 10% que ce
sera récurrent je dis juste non
c'est pas vrai il y a des employeurs qui
le font d'autres non la différence c'est
que quand vous employez de manière
durable une augmentation de salaire très
clairement c'est une charge pour
l'entreprise votre vie s'améliore mais
il faut que dans la durée la situation
de l'entreprise le permet les artisans
qui nous écoutent les entrepreneurs le
savent donc la nature n'est pas la même
mais je voudrais pas que celles et ceux
qui nous écoutent pensent qu'avec vous
leur salaire va augmenter de 10%
automatique pardon mais je crois que je
peux revenir au blocage des prix Madame
Le Pen parce que je suis content
d'apprendre que vous le maintenez mais
vous avez voté contre quand il est passé
à l'Assemblée pourquoi
parce que je souhaite changer le système
de fond en comble parce que je veux
rester contre le blocage des prix parce
que je veux restituer aux Français un
des prix de l'énergie qui sont la
conséquence de l'investissement de leurs
parents de leur
chose Monsieur car vous voyez bien que
si nous avions des prix réguliers comme
nous les avions antérieurement nous
serions beaucoup moins sensibles à
l'évolution que nous vivons aujourd'hui
des prix de l'énergie qui sont la
conséquence aussi d'un prix encore une
fois de l'énergie qui est fixée au
niveau européen et qui n'est pas fixé
sur nos prix de production à nous qui
étaient très bas qui ont d'ailleurs fait
le bonheur des particuliers français et
la compétitivité pendant des années des
entreprises françaises mais sur
l'ensemble des erreurs idé logique
effectuée par nos voisins notamment il
faut bien dire nos voisins allemands qui
sont très dépendants au gaz russe et
donc très dépendant à des variations
liées à des difficultés géopolitiques
mais pardonnez-moi je termine
moi je
suis
parfaitement d'accord pour
mettre une mesure supplémentaire qui est
une mesure pour le coup vous voyez
toutes les mesures dont je viens de vous
parler sont pérennes et qui est une
mesure conjoncturelle qui est la
suppression totale de la TVA
c'est-à-dire une TVA 0 % sur un panier
de 100 produits de première nécessité
d'hygiène ou alimentaire tant que la
l'inflation est supérieure d'un point à
la croissance ce qui est le cas
évidemment actuellement oui
oui oui c'est le cas actuellement oui
oui dans les chiffres constatés ou prévu
dans les chiffres prévus et dans les
chiffres du deuxième trimestre aussi
les chiffres de 2e trimestre l'inflation
et de 4 et demi pour cent et la
croissance de 0,6% et dans les
prévisions de la Banque de France la
croissance de 2,8% et la station de
4,4%. donc je pense que cette mesure
évidemment se mettra en place
extrêmement rapidement et là d'ailleurs
parce que ça démontre que la situation
est très difficile d'abord je me
félicite que malgré un vote négatif en
tant que député de la République quand
il s’agit de mettre en place le bouclier
qui ne mesurer médiate vous soyez pour
le garder c'est une bonne chose moi
cette correction de jugement pourquoi
parce que la réforme du marché européen
ne se fait pas en un mois Madame Le Pen
et c'est ce que nous avons lancé il y a
une différence entre vous et moi vous ce
que vous avez déclaré c'est vouloir
sortir du marché européen de l'énergie
et c'est une immense erreur parce que
nous sommes interconnectés parce que
nous avons des moments où nous importons
l'énergie que nous produisons pas sur le
sol français et comme nous sommes
interconnectés nous avons besoin du
marché européen simplement il faut c'est
ce que la France a entrepris sous sa
présidence pour ça qu'il faut réformer
l'Europe faut pas en sortir et bien
c'est ce que j'ai lancé il faut pouvoir
justement réformer le marché de
l'électricité pour qu'il ne dépendent
plus les petites paradictionnelles de
gaz parfois qu'on importe mais de la
base installée en particulier d'un autre
qui est beaucoup plus le nucléaire c'est
ce que nous avons engagé qui permettra
de baisser les prix vraiment faut faire
quelques mois et donc même quand on
lance cette réforme ce que la France a
fait et que j'assume on doit faire le
bouclier c'est pour ça qu'on l'a fait et
que je regrette que vous ayez voté
ensuite sur la TVA sur les produits
alimentaires moi je propose le chèque
alimentaire chaque alimentaire que je
voudrais comme le chèque inflation qui
touche les étudiants précaires les
modestes les ménages qui en ont le plus
besoin qui sont à l'Europe je pense
c'est à la fois plus efficace et plus
juste pourquoi d'abord parce que la TVA
0% sur les produits alimentaires que
vous proposez c'est pas une mesure
efficace parce qu'elle est très peu
répercutée plusieurs instituts
indépendants ont d'ailleurs dit ça fera
très heureux par an enfin de des
chiffres très bas je veux me risquerais
même pas sur ces chiffres quand on avait
fait la TVA pour nos restaurateurs
fallait le faire c'était une très bonne
mesure le président Sarkozy avait raison
mais c'était pourquoi on en a vu une
partie sur les prix marginales c'était
pour aider nos restaurateurs à embaucher
à repartir là votre baisse de la TVA
elle va aller au grand distributeur
beaucoup plus qu'au consommateur Madame
Le Pen et en plus elle est injuste cette
mesure elle est injuste parce que vous
et moi on n'a pas besoin de payer 0 % de
TVA sur ses biens on veut que les
ménages qui en ont le plus besoin qui
sont à leur prêt qui arrive pas à finir
de compléter le caddie puisse toucher
quelque chose le chèque est plus adapté
que la baisse de TVA qui elle n'est pas
ciblée donc ça va nous coûter des
milliards alors que ça va profiter à des
gens comme nous quatre qui n'en n'avons
pas besoin et ça la différence j'ajoute
à ça que quand je regarde les chiffres
de la Banque de France le taux
d'inflation 2022 moyenne année de 3,7 le
taux de croissance de 3 4 il y a pas un
point de différence il en est même des
chiffres du FMI et quand je regarde les
chiffres réalisés vous avez parlé du 4,5
d'inflation faut prendre les chiffres
trimestriels de croissance ils sont de
5,4 parce que c'est trimestre donc j'ai
regardé les chiffres parce que ça
m'intéressait de voir comment une
différence et donc ça s'appliquera
donc ça veut dire que dans aucun cas je
n'ai trouvé que votre dispositif pouvait
s'appliquer aujourd'hui en quelques
secondes
vous bloquez les prix mais vous auriez
pu quand même baisser la les taxes que
vous avez augmentées
mais vous vous souvenez que c'est parce
que vous avez augmenté les taxes sur le
carburant que ça a déclenché d'abord des
problèmes de pouvoir d'achat pour les
Français mais également la crise des
gilets jaunes et bien vous avez suspendu
cette Haus vous l'avez suspendu vous
n'avez pas retiré d'ailleurs
demain reprendre la trajectoire
d'augmentation que vous aviez envisagé
aux Français vous faites encore une fois
des chèques moi je vous dis que l'échec
sont inflationnistes comme ça toujours
été le cas dans toutes les économies
qu'on vous faites des chèques ça
entretient laflation parce que
évidemment les commerçants se disent bon
bah comme de toute façon il va y avoir
un chèque autant maintenir les prix
hauts la suppression de la TVA est
désinflationniste donc là encore vous
mettez en oeuvre des mesures qui
risquent d'aggraver la situation donc je
suis navré de vous dire que
les mesures que vous proposez sont en
même temps
inefficaces elles sont parfois mal
calibrées
j'ai vu que le chèque de 100 euros que
vous aviez adressé même des détenus dans
les prisons les avaient touché pour
compenser leur frais de carburant bon il
est beaucoup plus simple de leur rendre
de manière pérenne leur argent parce que
c'est leur argent
mais c'est normal parce que je pense que
vous n'avez pas de réponse et non mais
parce que vous n'avez pas répondu Madame
Le Pen d'abord je vais vous dire que ce
que vous avez dit est factuellement faux
le bouclier que nous avons mis en place
les chiffres sont là pour le constater
fait que la France a deux fois moins
d'inflation que l'Espagne 60% de moins
que l'Allemagne et que à peu près tous
nos voisins parce que le bouclier qu'on
a mis en place au contraire il est pas
inflationniste il évite que la hausse
qu'on ne répercute pas sur les ménages
se traduisent par ailleurs donc ce que
vous avez dit c'est exactement contraire
des faits vérifiables aujourd'hui la
deuxième chose
je vous le redis vos mesures comme elles
sont dans la durée qu'elles ne sont pas
ciblées du tout puisque vous baissez la
TVA pour nous quatre elles sont toutes à
la fois inefficaces parce qu'elles ne
seront pas transmises vraiment dans les
prix comme on le sait mais elles sont en
plus injustes
c'est la fin de ce premier thème on
regarde les chronomètres vous êtes à peu
près au même temps de parole sur le
pouvoir d'achat on va pouvoir passer à
l'international bravo à vous autre
chapitre extrêmement important ces
circonstances
l'international le 24 février dernier
l'Ukraine pays indépendants et reconnu
pays européens a été envahi et agressés
par la Russie que doit faire la France
jusqu'où doit aller la France pour aider
l'Ukraine Emmanuel Macron
d'abord vous avez raison de poser la
question internationale évidemment par
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui sur le sol
européen et le retour de la guerre dans
notre sur notre continent et nous vivons
des moments qui sont d'une extrême
gravité puisque la Russie a décidé
d'accroître son offensive et que les
prochaines heures les prochains jours
seront marqués par une absence
inoffensive de plus en plus massive sur
l'est de l'Ukraine donc le don basse sur
Mario Paul avec les drames humains comme
ceux que nous avons pu constater dans
plusieurs villes le rôle de la France
et le rôle de l'Europe
c'est comme nous l'avons fait puis le
début d'abord de soutenir l'Ukraine pour
résister de soutenir en aidant les
Ukrainiens avec des équipements de
défense et des équipements aussi pour
combattre pour ne pas que kievtombe de
soutenir l'Ukraine financièrement les
dents que nous avons fait ce que nous
avons refait de soutenir le peuple
ukrainien l'accueillant 5 millions du
crayon et d'ukrainien au moins ont
quitté le sol pour rejoindre l'Europe et
ça va complètement changer la vie de
l'Europe faut-il aller plus loin vous
demander Gilles Bouleau et donc je pense
qu'il faut aujourd'hui intensifier et
tenir cette ligne avec beaucoup de force
comme nous le faisons en veillant comme
je le fais depuis le début
à ce que cette guerre n'aille pas dans
une escalade et qu'elle ne s'étendent
pas et donc en parallèle il nous faut
renforcer la tenaille que nous mettons
en place avec les Européens et les
alliés et il nous faut également tenir
les autres pays c'est pour ça que j'ai
sans cesse discuter avec les Chine avec
l'Inde avec les pays du Golfe pour qu'il
puisse avec nous prendre conscience que
la Russie aujourd'hui choisit une voix
qui est funeste pour l'Ukraine au
premier chef mais pour elle-même et
l'équilibre des nations et donc c'est
pour ça que l'Europe est si importante
une Europe forte qui peut peser une
Europe avec des puissances de défense
forte comme la France et c'est pourquoi
j'ai réinvesti ces cinq dernières années
massivement dans nos armées pour avoir
un modèle complet d'armée aller vers les
50 milliards conformément à la loi de
programmation militaire mais faire de la
France et de l'Europe aussi une
puissance d'équilibre qui permettent
d'assurer notre sécurité dans la durée
c'est-à-dire d'éviter l'élargissement du
conflit parce que nous ne sommes les
vasseaux de personnes et de
progressivement ramener la Russie à la
raison pour d'abord cesser le feu puis
le territoire
ukrainien on va reparler de l'Union
européenne et de l'Europe je pense que
vous n'avez pas exactement la même
vision de ce que doit être l'Union
européenne on va y venir dans un instant
mais d'abord la même question exactement
la même pour vous Marine Le Pen doit-on
aider davantage l'Ukraine et lui livrer
des arbres faut-il aller plus loin
d'abord permettre moi d'évoquer ce soir
devant les millions de compatriotes qui
nous regardent ma solidarité et ma
compassion absolue avec le peuple
ukrainien je considère que l'agression
dans l'Ukraine a été victime n'est pas
admissible et j'avoue que les efforts
monsieur Macron que vous avez développé
pour tenter de trouver au nom de la
France les moyens les voies de la paix
mérite d'être soutenu c'est extrêmement
clair
l'aide à l'Ukraine oui bien sûr l'aide
humanité à l'Ukraine oui bien sûr l'aide
financière à l'Ukraine oui bien sûr
l'aide de matériel de défense oui bien
sûr évidemment
le maire de vous le savez de Perpignan
lui a lieu jusqu'à la frontière
polonaise pour ramener d'ailleurs des
réfugiés des femmes des enfants des
personnes âgées
ukrainien et les mettre en sécurité à à
Perpignan
la Pologne en est près de 3 millions de
réfugiés qu'elle a accueilli les
les alertes que j'avais pu lancer était
la limite c'est vous l'avez d'ailleurs
semble-t-il trouvé entre l'aide et la
cobelligence en matière de livraison
d'armes et l'autre
limite était les sanctions
j'étais d'accord moi sur l'intégralité
des sanctions qui ont été prises contre
les oligarques contre les banques contre
tout cela la seule sanction contre
lequel avec laquelle je suis en
désaccord c'est le blocage de
l'importation du gaz et du pétrole russe
pourquoi parce que je pense que ça n'est
pas la bonne méthode ça n'est pas ce qui
fera du mal en réalité à la Russie et
que surtout ça va faire énormément de
mal au peuple français et que les
conséquences de ce blocage dont on nous
annonce d'ailleurs que il serait négocié
par l'Union européenne après l'élection
présidentielle française aurait des
conséquences cataclysmiques pas
seulement d'ailleurs sur les
particuliers mais également sur les les
entreprises donc je pense que on ne peut
pas se faire hara-kiri avec l'espoir en
réalité de faire du mal financièrement à
la Russie qui très certainement ira
vendre son gaz et son pétrole à d'autres
pays donc ça a été la seule limite que
j'ai exprimé et puis j'ai exprimé aussi
une crainte j'ai exprimé une crainte qui
est une crainte ancienne ancienne de
notre pays et ancienne d'autres grandes
puissances du monde qui est de faire en
sorte que la Russie et la Chine
devienne des alliés si étroits qui
constituent demain parce que c'est ça
aussi gouverner c'est prévoir c'est
prévoir les dangers d'aujourd'hui et y
répondre et les dangers de demain une
superpuissance une superpuissance
économique une superpuissance monétaire
une superpuissance peut-être même
militaire qui pourrait constituer un
danger absolument majeur pour l'Occident
pour l'Europe et pour la France
voilà les
limites que j'ai exprimé les les alertes
que j'ai lancé parce que je crois encore
une fois que l'on est obligé dans un
monde complexe comme celui-là de ce
projeter à moyen et à long terme pour
éviter demain de créer des dangers qui
soient des dangers majeurs Emmanuel
Macron le jour où cette guerre
s'arrêtera faudra-t-il lever
immédiatement les sanctions contre la
Russie et ce que nous pourrons nous
Français considérer Vladimir Poutine
comme un partenaire à part entière un
partenaire comme un autre d'abord je
prend note des positions de Madame Le
Pen qui ne correspondent pas opposition
que votre partie et vos parlementaire
défendent Parlement européen par
parenthèse et qu'il s'agisse de protéger
jésus-christiens quand ils viennent sur
notre sol comme des sanctions
additionnelles après le premier paquet
comme de l'aide à l'Ukraine d'ailleurs à
laquelle vous êtes aussi opposé l'aide
financière c'est faux non c'est un fait
Madame Le Pen c'est faux ce sont les
votes et c'est d'ailleurs ce que vous
venez de dire complètement le contraire
des positions que vous avez
historiquement tenues vous avez été je
pense une des premières responsables
politiques européennes dès 2014 à
reconnaître le résultat de l'annexion de
la Crimée
je rappelle que
en droit international on reconnaît
rarement c'est à dire qu'on ne le fait
plus de la deuxième guerre mondiale des
territoires qui sont annexés par la
force alors même que Vladimir Poutine
avait reconnu que les conditions ne se
référaud'homme en Crimée et télésiènes
vous l'avez fait pourquoi et je le dis
avec beaucoup de gravité ce soir parce
que ça pour notre pays c'est une
mauvaise nouvelle parce que vous
dépendez du pouvoir russe et que vous
dépendez de Monsieur Poutine parce que
quelques mois après avoir dit cela
Madame Le Pen vous avez contracté un
prêt en 2015 auprès d'une banque russe
la First tchèque Russian Bank proche du
pouvoir en septembre 2014 puis vous avez
ensuite reboutiqués ce prêt auprès
d'autres acteurs tout ça est totalement
transparent connu notifié notarié
qui sont impliqués d'ailleurs ensuite
dans la guerre en Syrie et donc vous ne
parlez pas à d'autres dirigeants vous
parlez à votre banquier quand vous
parlez de la Russie c'est ça le problème
Madame Le Pen alors peut-être que c'est
aussi ce qui ce qui fait que on le voit
bien dès qu'il y a des positions
courageuses et difficiles à prendre
ni vous niveau représentants de sons
et ça n'est pas hasard si il y a 5 ans
la Russie était intervenue dans la
campagne ce qui a été prouvé au mode
déstabilisé et si vous avez toujours été
ambigu sur le sujet parce que vous
n'êtes pas dans une situation de
puissance à puissance que vous ne pouvez
pas défendre correctement sur ce sujet
des intérêts de la France parce que vos
intérêts sont liés à des gens proches du
pouvoir russe Marine Le Pen vous avez
évidemment le pouvoir de répondre à ce
que bien dire Emmanuel Macron vous
dépendez du pouvoir russe vous dépendez
Macron parce que il a accès à
l'intégralité des informations des
services
français et puis vous êtes pertinemment
que ce qu'il dit est faux
c'est pertinemment que je suis une femme
absolument et totalement libre et que je
défends parce que je suis une patriote
et que je l'ai démontré toute ma vie la
France et les Français toujours en toute
circonstance maintenant ce que vous
dites plusieurs fois d'abord je vous ai
retrouvé un tweet que j'avais fait le 9
novembre 2014 je soutiens une Ukraine
libre qui ne soit soumise ni aux
États-Unis ni à l'Union européenne ni à
la Russie voilà ma position c'est la
même c'était la même en Irak en 2003
c'est la même pour l'Ukraine aujourd'hui
je considère
non mais pardon d'accord nous allons y
venir monsieur Macron nous allons y
venir la Crimée n'a pas dû vous poser
énormément de problèmes non plus puisque
vous avez reçu Monsieur Poutine en
grande pompe à Versailles vous avez reçu
en 2017 vous avez reçu Monsieur Poutine
à Briançon sur votre lieu de vacances
et vous avez d'ailleurs tenu à cette
occasion exactement les propos que je
tiens vous avez dit à cette occasion que
la Russie devait être réarrimée à
l'Europe vous avez dit qu'il fallait
faire l'Europe de Lisbonne à Vlady
Vostok donc ce que vous faites
aujourd'hui
dans une posture
je ne reviens sur aucune de mes
déclarations sur la Russie dans le cadre
de l'architecture de sécurité européenne
bien entendu est-ce que j'ai défendu
mais j'ai parlé d'un point précis qui
touche le financement de votre partie
est-ce que ce que j'ai dit est faux
Madame Le Pen oui monsieur Macron c'est
faux et c'est assez malhonnête il faut
être honnête très bien et donc tout ça
donc
obligé d'aller faire un prêt à
l'étranger donc vous l'avez c'est parce
que bien sûr mais tout le monde le sait
c'est de notoriété publique c'est parce
que aucune banque française
n'a voulu m'accorder de près et vous
trouviez ça à l'époque tellement
scandaleux que vous avez fait voter une
loi sur la banque de la démocratie vous
ne l'avez jamais mis en oeuvre pourquoi
d'ailleurs monsieur Macron ne l'avait
pas fait pourquoi n'est pas allé au bout
de cette banque de la démocratie dont
vous saviez que elle comblait un déficit
démocratique des banques qui avaient
l'air de choisir leur parti politique ou
d'ailleurs pendant les élections le les
candidats qu'elles soutenaient ou
qu'elles ne soutenait pas monsieur
Macron je vais vous dire quelque chose
Monsieur Macron lui avait contracté en
2015 et vous ne l'avez toujours pas
remboursé et pas un sujet de banque de
la démocratie d'autres candidats à cette
élections qui défendaient des idées
proches des vôtres comme monsieur
Zemmour ils ont pas été chercher des
prêts en Hongrie ou en Russie voyons
trouver des prêts en France mais
monsieur Macron oui c'est long c'est
long à rembourser une remboursement sous
le contrôle de la Commission nationale
des comptes de campagne et croyez-moi la
Commission des comptes de campagne est
extrêmement sévère et rigoureuse voilà
donc et puis j'ai autre chose à vous
dire Monsieur Macron il y a des millions
de Français qui dans les cinq dernières
années sont allés dans des banques
françaises pour faire des prêts pour
acheter des voitures pour faire des
emprunts pour leur maison il ne vous
doivent rien
la seule chose qui doivent ces
rembourser leurs prêts exactement comme
moi mais comme votre serviteur aussi
madame simplement ils vont dans comme
vous l'avez dit dans des banques
françaises pour payer leur voiture qui
vont pas chercher plusieurs millions
dans une banque russe liée au pouvoir
qu'il ne rembourse pas c'est ça la
différence que tout le monde non mais
tout le monde ne comprendrons
je ne peux pas vous laisser dire qu'on
ne rembourse pas nous remboursons tous
les mois
rubiceront sous le contrôle de la
Commission nationale des Condes je ne
peux pas vous laisser toujours pas
remboursé ce prêt c'est assez long
monsieur Macron oui c'est vrai nous
sommes un parti pauvre mais c'est pas
déshonorant mais je n'ai jamais
considéré que c'était déshonorant mais
mon problème Madame Le Pen vous le
reconnaîtrez avec moi c'est que ceci
créé une dépendance je n'ai pas d'autres
dépendances que de rembourser mon prêt
monsieur Macron n'a pas été contracté
auprès d'une banque lambda même en
Russie mais auprès des intérêts et du
pouvoir et chacun pourra le vérifier et
donc assumez le c'est tout fais-le
Madame Le Pen c'était beaucoup de vos
choix derrière s'explique par cette
dépendance mais ça n'est pas je ne vous
en fais pas grief je dis simplement que
d'autres candidats défendant des idées
proches des vôtres n'ont pas fait les
mêmes choix et qu'ils ont trouvé des
financements
dans des banques françaises européennes
que vous vous avez fait un choix qui
manifestement vous a ensuite contraint
dans votre position politique et qui ne
vous rend pas indépendante sur cette
question c'est un fait c'est faux je
vous le redis
on est tous à vous écouter je crois que
les Français
et j'en ai eu comme tous nos
compatriotes qui pour acheter une maison
qui pour acheter un véhicule si vous
laissez l'exemple que vous avez pris on
n'est aucun d'entre nous ne sommes allés
les chercher auprès de banques rue c'est
encore moi des banques qui étaient
proches du pouvoir c'est quand même
assez malhonnête monsieur Macron
c'est malhonnête de m'empêcher d'obtenir
un prêt dans une banque française et de
me reprocher après de partir à
l'étranger pour en chercher vous rigolez
ou quoi en 2015 je vous ai empêché de
trouver un prêt dans une banque
française vous étiez bien ministre de
l'Économie des Finances l'économie il
n'y a pas les banques Emmanuel et en
plus personne n'est jamais intervenu
vous le savez très bien Emmanuel Macron
Marine Le Pen il reste une question très
importante
mais il y a l'Europe parce qu'on a parlé
là justement si vous le permettez c'est
l'Union européenne évidemment puisque il
reste très peu de temps sur le sujet de
l'international avant de passer à la
question des retraites si vous le voulez
bien la question de l'Union européenne
la question est simple elle vous est
posée à l'un et à l'autre souhaitez-vous
rester dans l'Union européenne telle
qu'elle est aujourd'hui avec le couple
franco-allemand comme moteur
je regarde les chronomètres c'est vous
Emmanuel Macron qui avait un petit peu
de retard vous avez la parole
vous savez pour ma part j'ai toujours
été clair notre débat d'ailleurs il y a
5 ans avait en grande partie porté sur
ce sujet
il y a 5 ans je note que 80% du
programme n'était applicable que si on
sortait de l'euro on avait tourné autour
de l'euro et de l'écu on n'avait pas
bien compris ce qui se passait je
comprends qu'aujourd'hui vous en fait
vous voulez en sortir toujours parce que
pas tellement changé de programme mais
vous ne le dites plus moi je crois dans
l'Europe et je crois dans le coupe
franco-allemand je pense que le couple
franco-allemand c'est ce qui nous a
permis d'obtenir des accords et
d'avancer quand nous avons eu la
pandémie la France vous savez une
produisait pas de vaccins ARN messager
on était tous très heureux d'en avoir en
janvier 2021 on l'a fait parce qu'on a
eu un accord européen on est ensuite
devenu le premier continent producteur
puis exportateur de vaccins pour
nous-mêmes notre sécurité celle des
autres nous avons en européen parce
qu'il y a d'abord eu un accord
franco-allemand bat-il une politique de
solidarité financière de mutualisation
des dettes futures
nous avons ensemble commencé à mettre en
place les fondements d'une Europe de la
défense
et donc moi je suis convaincu en effet
que notre souveraineté est nationale et
européenne et que les deux se complètent
et que c'est l'Europe qu'on sera plus
indépendant pour notre énergie
pour notre technologie pour notre
défense pour notre agroalimentaire et
parler d'Europe c'est parler aussi de
nos agriculteurs qu'ils savent combien
l'Europe est importante pour eux puisque
la Pâque les aides à vivre à évoluer à
faire avancer cette nouvelle révolution
que alors que T nous conduisons et donc
surtout ces sujets on a oui besoin d'une
Europe plus forte plus intégrée et pour
faire avancer l'Europe il faut un couple
franco-allemand de confiance ce que nous
avons su faire avec la chancelière
Merkel est-ce que nous faisons
aujourd'hui avec le chancelier Scholtz
je crois que c'est la bonne ligne pour
le pays même question Marine Le Pen dans
votre programme vous dites que vous
souhaitez l'avènement d'une alliance
européenne des nations qui se
substitueraient progressivement à
l'Union européenne est-ce à dire que
vous voulez sortir de l'Union européenne
ou que l'Union européenne telle qu'elle
est aujourd'hui vous convient avec le
couple franco-allemand comme moteur
d'abord permettez-moi de dire à Emmanuel
Macron que il n'y a pas de souveraineté
européenne car il n'y a pas de peuple
européen il y a une souveraineté que
lorsqu'il y a un peuple donc il y a une
souveraineté française il n'y a pas de
souveraineté européenne et j'ai bien
compris que vous souhaitiez remplacer la
souveraineté française par la
souveraineté européenne vous en avez
d'ailleurs vous l'avez fait d'ailleurs
symboliquement en remplaçant le drapeau
français sous l'Arc de Triomphe par le
drapeau par le drapeau européen l'Europe
c'est pas tout ou rien c'est pas on
prend tout et on ne dit rien ou alors on
ne prend rien je souhaite rester dans
l'Union européenne je souhaite
profondément la faire modifier pour
effectivement faire émerger une alliance
européenne des nations pourquoi parce
que d'abord il y a toute une série de
politiques de l'Union européenne avec la
avec lesquelles je suis en désaccord je
suis en désaccord avec la multiplication
des accords de libre-échange où on vend
des voitures allemandes en sacrifiant
des éleveurs
à la concurrence
des poulets du Brésil ou du boeuf du
Canada je suis en désaccord avec la
politique je suis en désaccord avec la
politique de du travailleur détachés qui
font qui font que des
milliers des dizaines de milliers des
centaines de milliers même
de travailleurs détachés viennent dans
notre pays travaillent et que les
charges qu'ils payent ne sont pas payées
en France mais sont payés dans leur pays
d'origine je suis opposé à la politique
que vous avez soutenue de la ferme à la
fourchette qui vise à baisser de 10 à
20% la production agricole européenne au
moment où le monde est en train de faire
face à une crise alimentaire qui va voir
un certain nombre de pays probablement
être victimes d'émeutes de la fin donc
il y a toute une série effectivement de
politique dont je me dis pourquoi la
France n'arrive jamais à défendre ses
intérêts pourquoi moi qui a été député
européenne j'ai vu l'Allemagne défende
sur des dossiers ses intérêts pieds à
pied je n'ai jamais vu les dirigeants
français défendent des intérêts des
Français
défendre des intérêts de des producteurs
des éleveurs des industriels français
je souhaite faire donc je souhaite
encore une fois que la Commission
respecte les nations souveraines
respectent leur choix y compris leur
choix de société car nous faisons des
choix de société par les votes qu'ils
font les Français font des choix de
société et je considère que la
Commission européenne doit les respecter
donc je veux faire évoluer cette
organisation européenne mais monsieur
Macron je ne pensais pas que vous
tomberiez dans une forme de complotisme
je n'ai je ne souhaite pas en sortir si
vous souhaitez je trouve ça séduisant je
le dirai si je dis que je ne souhaite
pas en sortir c'est que je ne souhaite
pas le faire donc 80% du programme a
changé c'est une bonne nouvelle par
rapport à 5 ans puisque 80% étaient
applicable sans euros mais je vais
revenir sur ce que vous disiez d'abord
dans votre programme il y a de fait
changer tout seul un club en réduisant
sa cotisation en disant je choisis mes
règles
soit les autres vous suivent parce que
c'est ça l'Europe on est 27 autour de la
table soit vous faites bande à part
est-ce que vous décrivez ça ressemble à
une bande à part dans votre programme la
deuxième chose vous proposez une
alliance avec la Russie dans vos
priorités c'est toujours dans votre
programme c'était étonnant ensuite vous
avez cité deux choses qui sont
importantes les poulets brésiliens je
veux d'abord vous informer que la France
s'est opposée au Mercosur et cette
opposé au Mercosur parce que j'ai
justement porté une clause miroir c'est
à dire le fait que quand nous on demande
à nos agriculteurs nos industriels des
choses on demande la même chose en face
et donc nous n'avons nous avons refusé
d'avancer sur ce dossier parce qu'il n'y
avait pas de respect des engagements de
Paris du respect de la biodiversité et
on a lutté d'ailleurs contre la
déforestation importée grâce à l'Europe
et pour nos agriculteurs la deuxième on
s'est battus pour une Pâque qui ne
baisse pas malgré le brexit tous les
autres voulaient faire baisser à
quelques exceptions près et on se bat
aujourd'hui pour en effet parce que je
partage que vous avez dit sur les
baisses de production ils sont plus
adaptés au contexte c'est la position
française je vous en informe et donc il
faut pouvoir produire plus en protégeant
plus
sur le travail détaché il n'y a pas des
centaines de milliers de travailleurs
détachés il y a environ 500 000 tâches
en France qui correspond à environ 50
000 travailleurs détachés mais on a fait
la réforme parce que moi depuis 5 ans je
me bats pour changer cette Europe elle
ne sait pas faite spontanément l'Europe
que je décris celle du vaccin dont ça
n'était pas les compétences l'Europe de
la solidarité de la mutualisation de la
dette pour convaincre les Allemands
c'est une bataille française de chaque
jour que j'ai mené depuis 5 ans mais je
me suis battu dans le respect des autres
et pour le faire sur le travail détaché
on a changé les règles pour avoir un
travail égal salaire égal pour lutter
justement contre ce qui ne marchait pas
dans votre programme quand j'essaie de
comprendre ce qu'il y a derrière votre
réforme du travail détaché vous voulez
quasiment le supprimer
mais vous irez l'expliquer
centaines de milliers de Françaises et
de Français qui sont travailleurs
détachés dans des pays voisins parce que
beaucoup de ne transfrontaliers vivent
avec ce système Marine Le Pen Emmanuel
mais derrière cela des valeurs de
l'Europe et des règles du Conseil de
l'Europe jusqu'au marché de l'énergie
dont vous proposez de sortir jusqu'à
Schengen sur laquelle vous n'êtes pas
clair votre projet quand on remet
bric-à-brique les choses en place c'est
un projet qui ne dit pas son nom mais
qui consiste à faire sortir de l'Europe
des nations oui enfin si c'est plus
l'Union européenne vous sortez de
l'Union européenne même Le Pen non mais
pardon de vous le dire on peut on peut
décider de ripoliner tout seul la façade
mais enfin c'est pas c'est une
copropriété aucun moment donné dans une
copropriété vous pouvez pas dire du jour
au lendemain ça s'appelle plus la
copropriété ça s'appelle comme j'ai
décidé parce que je m'appelle Madame Le
Pen et bien j'ai beaucoup plus
d'ambition que vous mais Madame Le Pen
moi j'ai une ambition je la porte je le
fais dans le respect des autres et j'ai
fait avancer les choses mais je ne mens
pas sur la marchandise
vous montez sur la marchandise non je
n'en pas sur la marchandise tout le
monde sait que je défends l'Europe des
nations tout le monde sait qu'est-ce que
je ne veux pas dans cette union
européenne et qu'est-ce que je veux
changer et je le ferai je le ferai avec
des alliés vous me dites que vous avez
obtenu des grandes avancées sur les
travailleurs détachés c'est faux vous
avez juste obtenu qu'on arrête de
frauder c'est à dire que celui qui fait
un travail est le même salaire que celui
que le français oui mais les charges
continuent à être payées dans le pays
d'origine je suis désolé de vous dire
que je considère oui mais je considère
que c'est une perte nette pour notre
pays et que du coup et que du coup
pardon est-ce que je peux terminer une
phrase s'il vous plaît monsieur Macron
est-ce que je peux terminer une phrase
et que surtout ça crée en réalité une
préférence étrangère à l'emploi dans un
certain nombre de secteurs j'explique un
peu comment ça se passe quand dans un
secteur une entreprise fait appel à des
travailleurs détaché évidemment ça lui
coûte moins cher et par conséquent les
autres entreprises sont obligées de
faire elle aussi appel à des
travailleurs détachés parce que sinon
elles ne sont plus compétitives et bien
cette préférence étrangère à l'emploi
je n'en veux pas car mon objectif ma
priorité mon obsession c'est justement
que les Français puissent travailler
dans leur propre pays c'est pour cela
que je me bats la valeur travail trouver
du travail créer du travail et restituer
des manuel Macron c'est pardon Emmanuel
Macron on est malheureusement maître des
horloges je dis juste
mais ensuite il faut passer au retraites
mais la préférence nationale à l'emploi
c'est la fin du marché unique européen
parce que vous pouvez pas dire quand un
Bulgare vient travailler en France je
n'en veux pas ou alors je veux qu'il
qu'il devienne français ou qui paye ses
impôts en France et demander que nous
nos travailleurs français continuent de
pouvoir aller travailler en Allemagne en
Belgique ou dans d'autres pays européens
c'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui vous
avez plein de transfrontaliers qui font
ça et donc c'est toujours pareil avec
vous vous pensez qu'on peut faire la
préférence nationale pour nous mais que
les autres ne nous demanderons pas mais
le marché européen c'est un marché de
libre circulation des travailleurs et de
libre circulation des marchandises
au moment des institutions ce que je
voudrais vous dire c'est que vous êtes
très européen au centre non
ce que j'ai de la France c'est que c'est
une puissance mondiale pas seulement une
puissance européenne or on n'a pas parlé
de l'Afrique avec lequel il faut
évidemment développer des nouvelles
relations on n'a pas parlé de de nos
outre-mer qui sont les plateformes
d'accord de nous outre-mer qui sont les
questions ne me coupez pas ils sont les
plateformes d'influence de la France
justement régionales à l'égard des pays
alentours on a parlé en réalité de rien
de tout ça pourquoi parce que vous avez
une vision qui rabougrit en fait la
France la France est un pays dans votre
esprit qui est devenu un pays
continental ça n'est pas un pays
continental c'est un pays mondial et
elle doit retrouver cette ambition de
grandeur cette ambition d'influence dans
le monde et y compris avec des
partenaires privilégiés et notamment des
pays francophones d'Afrique qui sont des
partenaires historiques avec lequel il
faut vraiment refonder une relation
n'oubliant
c'est fascinant de voir le cynisme avec
lequel vous pouvez avancer parce que que
quelqu'un qui parle de préférence
nationale contre l'Europe ce que vous
venez de faire en expliquant que donc le
marché européen finito que pareil sur
les marchandises puisque vous remettez
des contrôles aux frontières en
remettant autant de données qu'en 1990
je vais regarder précisément et vous
vous me parlez de rabougrissement vous
êtes nationaliste qui est plutôt pour le
rabouissement sur les frontières
nationales
vous n'avez pas parlé l'autre jour vous
avez fait une conférence sur
l'international vous n'avez pas eu un
mot sur l'Afrique allez je peux vous
dire moi j'ai fait plus de voyages
qu'aucun de mes prédécesseurs sur le
continent africain c'est un continent
auquel je tiens j'ai refondé cette
relation y compris en regardant avec
lucidité et courage notre histoire sur
ce sujet il y a pas votre cas mais je
peux vous dire quand il vous regarde ils
sont médusés ils sont médusés vous
voulez faire de la France le premier
pays au monde qui a interdirait le voile
sur la voie publique vous voulez faire
notre pays non mais
quand on dit je vais être une grande
puissance mondiale qui rayonne le projet
que vous portez est un projet de
rétrécissement et un projet qui est
attentatoire à l'universalisme français
c'est normal c'est le projet on est
Front national
Emmanuel Macron il est historique
vous aurez choisir l'un et l'autre
devrait parler en longueur de ces thèmes
et on est obligé de passer au thème
suivant vos échanges sont passionnants
je pense que les Français voient
précisément vos différences sur
l'international et sur l'Europe mais on
doit passer à un thème qui a été très
débattu dans cette campagne et là encore
on voit vos désaccords jusqu'à quel âge
devons-nous travailler si vous êtes élu
l'un et l'autre soyons honnêtes vous
avez l'un et l'autre évoluer récemment
sur cette question et les Français ont
parfois du mal à comprendre ce que vous
proposez précisément Marine Le Pen pour
être clair vous présidente en 2027 à la
fin de votre quinquennat à quel âge les
Français partiront à la retraite ils
partiront à la retraite entre 60 et 62
ans pour avoir une retraite pleine il
leur faudra entre 40 et 42 annuités très
clairement moi le choix que j'ai fait
parce que philosophiquement je considère
que le système de protection sociale
c'est le bien de ceux qui n'en n'ont pas
c'est le patrimoine de ceux qui n'en
n'ont pas et il s'exprime par la
solidarité nationale je suis
profondément attaché parce que c'est un
des éléments de la Cinquième République
et quand on y touche en réalité on
touche aux institutions de la Cinquième
République et dans ce système de
protection sociale la retraite a un rôle
extrêmement important je pense que la
justice elle nécessite de considérer que
plus on travaille tout plus on travaille
dur et puis il faut partir tôt et par
conséquent je propose un système qui est
progressif tous ceux qui seront que ont
commencé qui auront eu un premier emploi
significatif avant l'âge de 20 ans entre
17 et 20 ans pourront partir à la
retraite à 60 ans après 40 années et
progressivement au fur et à mesure de
l'âge auquel on rentre dans le système
et bien on atteindra maximum 42 annuler
62 ans c'est évidemment fort différent
du projet de Monsieur Macron qui veut
faire travailler tout le monde jusqu'à
65 ans permettez-moi quand même de
rappeler parce que je sais que les amis
de Monsieur Macron ont essayé de créer
une incertitude et donc une inquiétude
auprès des Français que tout dispositif
particulier carrière longue et autres
sera évidemment
prioritaire sur ma réforme si quelqu'un
a grâce à un dispositif de carrière
longue un bénéfice plus avantageux pour
lui alors c'est le système de carrière
longue qui s'appliquera mais la retraite
à 65 ans c'est une injustice absolument
insupportable monsieur Macron
envisagez que les Français partent à la
retraite alors que ils seront ils seront
plus capables d'en profiter alors que
très certainement la majorité d'entre
eux ne seront plus en activité puisque
déjà 62 ans 8 mois ils sont déjà la
moitié à être en inactivité au moment où
ils prennent leur retraite envisager que
plus personne ne puisse avoir une
retraite pleine car plus personne
n'arrivera à cet âge là avec le nombre
d'annuités qui va évidemment augmenter
aussi vous le savez bien si vous
augmentez l'âge de départ à la retraite
vous augmentez évidemment le nombre le
nombre d'annuités je suppose on n'a pas
réussi à trop savoir
quoi qu'il en soit je considère que
c'est en même temps profondément injuste
et contrairement à ce que vous dites
absolument pas justifié sur le plan
budgétaire
Emmanuel Macron même question que Marine
Le Pen si vous êtes réélu président de
la République vous pouvez dire
clairement pouvez-vous dire clairement
aux Français ce soir à quel âge ils
partiront à la retraite à la fin d'un
éventuel second quinquennat en 2027 oui
d'abord on a beaucoup de progrès à
financer
sur et on l'a fait durant ce quinquennat
sur la santé et sur d'autres sujets et
on a continué en particulier pour le
grand âge et permettre l'autonomie
j'espère qu'on pourra en parler des plus
âgés d'entre nous on va on a aussi à
amélioré le niveau des retraites moi je
propose y compris pour toutes celles et
ceux qui sont aujourd'hui à la retraite
de passer ce qu'on appelle le minimum
contributif c'est-à-dire quelqu'un qui a
une carrière complète à 1100 euros parce
que ce qui est dans votre projet n'est
pas juste c'est que vous proposez la
même retraite pour quelqu'un qui n'a
jamais travaillé de sa vie et quelqu'un
qui a une vie de labeur dans les deux
cas vous leur proposez 1000 euros moi je
pense qu'il faut une différence et donc
moi je propose de passer la retraite le
minimum contributif qui est aujourd'hui
de 980 euros à 1100 euros ces progrès
faut pouvoir les financer et avant même
ces progrès notre régime est
déséquilibré et il est jusqu'au milieu
des années 2030 nous dit l'organisme
indépendant qui est en charge qui
s'appelle le corps et c'est normal parce
que la crise est passée par là
et donc moi je veux garder ce trésor je
partage que vous avez dit au début de
votre propos qui est notre système par
répartition c'est à dire que les actifs
payent pour les retraités et donc moi je
ne veux pas d'un projet qui fragilise
les pensions de notre retraités vous
n'êtes pas clair là-dessus moi je veux
continuer d'améliorer les pensions et
les mettre à 1100 euros pour ceux qui
ont une carrière complète je ne veux pas
que les impôts augmentent quand je vous
dis ça je suis crédible je les ai baissé
pendant le quinquennat qui vient de
s'achever de 50 milliards d'euros dont
25 milliards pour les ménages
faut payer plus de taxe d'habitation
vous avez les impôts sur le revenu en
baissé donc je suis crédible quand je
dis ça donc je veux pas baisser je veux
pas monter les impôts je veux qu'il
baisse je ne veux pas augmenter notre
dette je veux commencer à la rembourser
sous ce quinquennat qui vient c'est les
Françaises et les Français me font
confiance et donc il n'y a qu'une
manière de financer c'est de travailler
progressivement plus avec un pilier qui
est le plein emploi ou pour y revenir
parce que le travail pour moi est un fil
rouge c'est à dire réussir à faire comme
ce qu'on a fait sous ce quinquennat et
un deuxième pilier qui est de décaler
l'âge légal qui est de 62 ans
aujourd'hui de 4 mois par an ce qui veut
dire que vous atteindrez en 2028 64 ans
et en 2031 65 ans est-ce que j'ai ouvert
c'est l'idée d'une clause de revoyure
c'est pas du jour au lendemain comme
vous le laissez entendre c'est pas vrai
c'est 4 mois par an mais en prenant en
compte plusieurs dispositifs le premier
carrière longue il faut garder un tel
dispositif vous avez raison
le deuxième c'est la pénibilité vous
vous proposez de supprimer le système de
pénibilité je pense c'est une mauvaise
idée parce que il y a des gens comme
nous nous quatre objectifs
si j'en crois tout ceux toutes celles et
ceux qui sont dans nos secteurs bon donc
il faut de la liberté il faut pouvoir
protéger ceux qui ont par contre des
métiers pénibles qui puissent partir
bien avant ce que vous avez raison pour
beaucoup de métiers à 40 annuités par
exemple non Madame Le Pen parce que là
je les garde justement me permet de ne
pas revenir sur ces sujets là mais vous
vous êtes pas juste davantage parce que
comme vous ne prenez pas en compte les
critères de pénibilité chez vous
professionnels qui commencerait un
métier pénible à 25 ans il va jusqu'à 67
ans dans votre système
vous savez très bien
donc ce que je dis c'est que les
critères de pénibilité permettent d'être
vu c'est ça qu'il faut qu'on sortait
avec les syndicats donc un carrière
longue de pénibilité individualisée pour
les ouvriers agricoles pour nos
compatrices qui travaillent pendant les
abattoirs qui travaillent de nuit
transporteur routier faut qu'ils
puissent partir plus tôt et trois fois
supprimer principaux régimes spéciaux et
donc les personnes qu'on embauche dans
ces régimes en particulier la RATP EDF
doivent être embauchés dans un régime
spécial eux doivent rentrer dans le
système général pourquoi je fais ça pour
pouvoir financer les progrès parce que
on va y revenir vous vous l'expliquez
jamais comment vous financez vos progrès
vous n'êtes pas honnête avec les gens
moi j'explique c'est pas grave pour se
faire élire c'est plus simple de dire
qu'on revient sur une réforme antérieure
ce que vous faites mais vous revenez sur
un système qui n'est déjà pas équilibré
donc soit vous avez des impôts cachés
soit vous allez mettre en péril les
pensions des retraités
qui a créé 600 milliards d'euros de
dettes supplémentaires en 5 ans dont
deux tiers qui n'ont rien à voir avec le
covid
supplémentaire
non strictement rien à voir sont les
chiffres d'ailleurs de vos propres
ministères qui évoquent 145 milliards
pour le covid tout le reste c'est de
l'aggravation de la tête
mais arrêtez de tout confondre c'est pas
possible ne me donnez pas de leçons
de mon projet
Madame Le Pen alors Emmanuel Macron
qu'est-ce que vous auriez fait on a 600
milliards d'euros de dettes on a baissé
le déficit les premières années du
quinquennat et la dette a commencé à
être remboursée les 600 milliards
d'euros de dettes c'est 200 milliards de
la partie état le reste c'est la
sécurité sociale et les collectivités
locales pourquoi parce que comme les
gens ne pouvaient plus travailler on n'a
pas prélevé leur cotisation figurez-vous
parce que on a même fait des décalages
voir des exonérations de cotisations
mais le quoi qu'il en coûte Madame Le
Pen vous avez voté contre vous auriez
fait quoi
qu'est-ce que vous auriez fait pendant
la crise covid Marine Le Pen vous avez
3000 de retard donc vous avez largement
la parole d'accord ça va me permettre de
revenir sur parce que vous vous dites je
vais répondre à tout y compris à
l'intégralité des choses totalement
fausses que vous avez pu dire depuis
tout à l'heure mais j'ai du mal à vous
suivre tellement il y en a vous avez dit
tout à l'heure que vous aviez baissé le
chômage bon le chômage qui est analysé
par le Bureau international du travail
c'est une un chiffrage qui est
extrêmement contesté vous le savez car
en réalité il est très restrictif et il
y a à l'eau autour d'ailleurs c'est si
vrai que en réalité les chiffres du
chômage c'est-à-dire les chômeurs
ABC était 5 millions 5 quand vous avez
été élu ils sont 5 millions 4 voilà
peut-être que le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est que vous n'avez pas
c'est le chômage alors on transfère les
uns dans la catégorie B dans la
catégorie c'est la a dans la B etc tout
ça ce sont des statistiques qui sont
bien connues ils n'en demeure pas moins
que des gens qui cherchent activement un
emploi il y en avait 5 millions 500 000
quand vous avez été il y en a 5 millions
400 000 aujourd'hui donc en matière de
succès sur le chômage permettez-moi tout
de même d'être dubitatif
vous nous expliquer que vous avez fait
beaucoup d'efforts pour les plus
modestes etc moi ce que je vois c'est
qu'il y a 400000 pauvres supplémentaires
sous votre quinquennat 400000 pauvres
sommes donc dans un pays où il y a 9
millions 800000 pauvres au moment où
nous nous parlons et ça aussi je suis
désolé de vous le dire c'est votre
résultat vous expliquer que vous êtes
très bon en économie que d'ailleurs les
entreprises vous adorent très bien il y
a 85 milliards de déficits de la balance
commerciale ça c'est un chiffre on peut
pas le pipoter c'est impossible ce qui
est un record absolu et peut-être le
chiffre le plus brutal le plus cruel
pour vous c'est le chiffre de la
productivité parce que en l'occurrence
le chiffre de la productivité il
décroche totalement monsieur Macron a
compté de votre élection
et l'augmentation de la productivité et
de 0,1%. alors qu'elle est de 1,8% pour
l'ensemble des pays de l'OCDE donc le
Mozart de la finance c'est comme ça que
on vous avait présenté je dis pas que
vous vous étiez présenté mais on vous
avait présenté à un bilan économique qui
est très mauvais j'ai oublié les 17000
ou 15000
14500 pardon emploi industriel perdus
sous votre quinquennat et un bilan
social qui est encore pire alors oui
quand je viens vous dire il y a un autre
projet à mettre en oeuvre il faut
changer les priorités il faut changer
les méthodes il faut changer la manière
dont on envisage l'économie il faut
faire du patriotisme économique il faut
faire de la relocalisation des activités
il faut réindustrialiser notre pays il
faut aider les très petites entreprises
et les petites et moyennes entreprises
en leur accordant des baisses de
fiscalité pas au le groupe monsieur
Macron comme vous l'avez fait car
lorsque vous parlez de baisse d'impôt
vous pensez toujours au gros et jamais
au petit quand vous parlez des baisses
d'impôts que vous avez fait pour les
Français vous oubliez de dire que la
plus grosse baisse ça a été évidemment
la suppression de l'info de l'impôt sur
les grandes fortunes
d'habitation
c'est la taxe d'habitation de très très
loin Madame Le Pen la taxe d'habitation
que les Français sont en train de payer
par la hausse de la taxe foncière Madame
Le Pen mais les chiffres que tout le
monde ait regardait les chiffres mais de
très très loin on vous entend débattre
sur le financement de vos programmes
respectifs Madame Le Pen vous le
constaterez en quelques cours de seconde
absolument pas répondu sur le covid j'ai
expliqué les 600 milliards de dettes que
c'était
c'est la dette covid c'est 600 milliards
de dettes je l'assume totalement parce
que vous savez on a eu une récession
trois fois plus lourde que pendant la
crise financière on en sort aujourd'hui
comme je le dis dans vos programmes il y
a pas de mode chômage pourquoi parce
qu'on a aidé mais que vous ayez l'autre
cuit danse de dire qu'on aide les grands
groupes mais que les restaurateurs que
les artisans que les commerçants que les
petits industriels qui nous écoutent
aujourd'hui mais viennent témoigner
viennent vous parler et vous dire qui
les a aidés pendant la crise covid qui
les a aidés avec le fond de solidarité
avec le chômage partiel avec les prêts
garantis avec la prise en charge parfois
de leur de leur propre cotisations c'est
le gouvernement je suis fier qu'on ait
fait ça c'est l'argent de la nation ce
600 milliards de dettes on a constitué
tous ensemble pour protéger ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui Madame Le Pen alors qu'on
a vécu une pandémie comme on en avait
pas vécu depuis un siècle on a malgré
tout contrairement aux chiffres que vous
pouvez donner baisser le chômage il est
passé de 9,6 à 7,4% et le Bureau
international du travail comme on
l'indique et l'organisme qui fait
référence il vous plaît peut-être pas
mais personne ne compte les catégories B
et C du chômage puisque ce sont des
actifs partiels
du chômage ne faites pas ils se sont
contents
les chiffres on parle de vie derrière
mais la vie de nos commerçants de nos
artisans c'est ça la dette covid vous
avez voté contre expliquez-moi quel
centime c'est la député Le Pen a voté la
député Le Pen a voté contre les votes
sont Emmanuel Macron
madame expliquer ce que vous auriez fait
autrement en quelques secondes madame le
penal en quelques secondes le premier
confinement j'avais proposé que des
fonds propres j'avais proposé des fonds
propres à tous les TPE PME j'avais
proposé 1500 euros par entreprise plus
1000 euros par salarié c'était des fonds
propres vous avez fait le choix d'un
certain nombre de prêts des PGE qui
aujourd'hui doivent être remboursés par
les entreprises elles n'y arriveront pas
beaucoup
beaucoup mourront on est des cadra mais
on les décalant d'accord mais on est des
Calanques vous savez ce que vous faites
vous les inscrivez sur les fichiers des
banques on fait du quasi font et donc
ils ne peuvent plus ils ne peuvent plus
investir pour tout le reste monsieur
Macron vous savez j'ai été en désaccord
avec vous après le premier confinement
vous avez continué les couvre-feu vous
avez continué de fermer les commerces en
considérant qu'il y avait les essentiels
et les non essentiels et bien avec tout
cela j'étais en désaccord pour une
raison simple c'est que à l'époque à
cette époque là après le premier
confinement on savait qu'en réalité les
petits commerces n'étaient pas le lieu
de transmission du virus vous avez donc
fait des fermetures administratives et
vous venez expliquer aujourd'hui que les
commerçants devraient vous être
reconnaissants de les avoir de leur
avoir compensé les pertes que vous avez
vous-même suscité en les fermant de
manière administrative je suis pas tout
à fait d'accord avec par définition
avec vous sur la période du covid
on voudrait passer à l'hôpital les
vaccins russes là encore Spoutnik que
vous proposiez d'administrer
donc si vous voulez tous vos amis tous
vos amis quand je regarde comment ils
ont géré la crise covid je suis plutôt
fier de la manière dont on la gérer s'il
vous plaît est-ce qu'on peut passer à
l'hôpital il y a beaucoup de thèmes que
vous vous avez envie de demander et on
aura plus le temps d'aborder on n'aura
plus le temps de les aborder vous voulez
parler de la dépendance on va parler de
l'hôpital ce sont des sujets extrêmement
majeurs vous parliez du covid l’hôpital
public il est menacé d'effondrement
c'est ce que disent les médecins les
aides-soignants les infirmiers ils le
disent encore plus depuis l'épidémie de
covid si vous êtes réélu Emmanuel Macron
qu'est-ce que vous leur dites à ces
personnels de santé ce soir ça ira
beaucoup mieux avec moi dans 5 ans
d'abord l'hôpital Vinck on a une crise
qui est à l'hôpital et dans ce qu'on
appelle les déserts médicaux dans
beaucoup de nos territoires qui
s'agissent d'ailleurs des quartiers
comme de la grande ruralité
et sur ce sujet les décisions étaient
prises dès 2018 j'ai mis fin à la baisse
de ce qu'on appelle le tarif hospitalier
j'ai mis fin à ce qu'on appelle le
numerus clausus on formait pas assez de
médecin malheureusement ça prend trop de
temps puis nous avons vécu la crise moi
j'ai une gratitude infinie à l'égard de
nos médecins et l'ensemble des soignants
nous avons pris une décision historique
pendant la crise à la fois
d'investissement
plus de 19 milliards d'euros dans nos
hôpitaux et d'investissement dans les
salaires puisque on a revalorisé les
salaires pour tous les soignants d'au
moins 183 euros par mois ce qui n'avait
jamais été fait jusqu'à plus de 400
euros en fin de carrière
ça n'est pas suffisant et donc ce que je
leur dis c'est que je sais tout ce que
je leur donne je sais la situation très
dure là parce qu'il y a à la fois le
manque de médecins historique le manque
de soignants historiques on va commencer
à améliorer les choses pour les
infirmiers les infirmières les
aides-soignants aide-soignantes dans les
mois qui viennent mais je sais aussi
qu'aujourd'hui ce sont les conditions de
travail qui sont les plus dures et donc
on doit continuer d'investir dans notre
système de santé pour redresser
l'hôpital et donc ré-embaucher pour
embaucher faut réattirer des gens à
l'hôpital améliorer les conditions de
travail il y a pas de secret et donc
continuer d'investir et il y a une série
de mesures on pourrait revenir dans le
détail que je propose pour mettre fin au
désert médicaux qui propose au fond de
méthode totalement nouvelle à l'échelle
d'un territoire c'est à dire de faire
travailler
nos personnels à l'hôpital avec notre
médecine de ville avec aussi ce qu'on
appelle les paramédicaux nos pharmaciens
et pharmaciennes nos infirmiers
infirmières de ville les kiné l'ensemble
de ces professions pour qu'on ait une
offre de soins qui soient organisée à
l'échelle d'un territoire et qui
permettent d'avoir un référente santé
pour nos compatriotes en particulier les
plus âgés qui aujourd'hui ont du mal à
trouver des médecins donc on va devoir
continuer à investir c'est dans mon
projet c'est pour ça que j'assume un
investissement massif sur le sujet de la
santé Marine Le Pen face à cet
effondrement de l'hôpital public
constaté par les professionnels de santé
si vous êtes élu président de la
République en 2027 est-ce que l'hôpital
ira beaucoup mieux oui il ira beaucoup
mieux il y aura beaucoup mieux moi je
frappé d'une chose c'est que en réalité
pendant votre quinquennat Emmanuel
Macron vous aurez attendu les crises ces
il n'y a que les crises qui arrivent à
vous faire bouger
il a fallu la crise sanitaire pour
s'apercevoir que le personnel soignant
était dans une souffrance absolument
inouïe depuis des années vous n'avez pas
fait preuve d'ailleurs beaucoup
d'empathie à son égard parce que quand
vous avez
licencié 15000 soignants 15000 soignants
sans salaire du jour au lendemain parce
que vous refusiez qu'il puisse tester
avant de venir travailler et que vous
vouliez à tout prix qu'ils soient
vacciné c'était pas bien de faire ça je
l'ai réintégrerai mon ce qui me concerne
et je le restituerai d'ailleurs des
salaires dont ils ont été privés mais il
a encore une fois fallu attendre la
crise or l'effondrement de l'hôpital on
le connaissait ils étaient déjà depuis
trois ans ou quatre ans au pouvoir 3 ans
donc vous auriez pu tout de suite
considérer que c'était une urgence vous
n'avez pas fait quand je fais donc
c'était l'effondrement les infirmières
sont en sous-effectif les déserts
médicaux ça date depuis des années plus
personne n'arrive à trouver des médecins
numéro exclusif vous l'avez supprimé
l'année dernière vous auriez pu le
supprimer 2018
madame bon bref quoi qu'il en soit quoi
qu'il en soit moi je crois qu'il faut
sortir 20 milliards sur cinq ans un
milliard sur 50 c'est 10 milliards pour
la revalorisation du personnel pour
l'embauche aussi de personnel notamment
dans les EHPAD pour éviter les drames
qui ont été révélés et puis la
souffrance en fait des soignants et des
patients parce que tous les infirmières
que j'ai rencontrés j'en ai rencontré
des dizaines et partout y compris en
outre-mer me disent on a pas le temps de
s'occuper des patients on n'a pas le
temps on n'est pas assez on n'a pas
assez de moyens du coup nous les
elles s'accusait elle-même près de dire
mais on a tellement pas de temps on
considère que c'est presque de la
maltraitance bon et bien à cette urgence
là il faut répondre rapidement donc 10
milliards sur la revalorisation
salariale qui sera de l'argent public je
le dis et 10 milliards d'investissements
dans l'hôpital pour le matériel
c'est-à-dire un plan scanner IRM et ça
ce sera financé par le fond souverain
donc j'espère nous aurons l'occasion de
parler tout à l'heure qui est un fond
sur fond privé et non pas sur fonds
publics moi je crois qu'il faut vraiment
développer la télémédecine il faut à
tout prix qu'on mette en place une
incitation financière fiscale pour les
médecins pour les inciter à aller
s'installer dans les zones soudances
mais ça ne suffira pas c'est l'ensemble
de la politique qu'il faut rééquilibrer
entre les métropoles et la ruralité car
vous aurez beau donner des incitations
financières aux médecins s'ils ne
peuvent pas s'ils peuvent pas venir avec
sa femme sa femme peut pas trouver
d'emploi qui a pas d'école pour les
enfants qui a pas de transport pour
aller à la ville d'à côté et bien en
réalité on continuera dans cette
notification qui est une injustice qui
est ressentie comme une injustice par
nos compatriotes profondes Marine Le Pen
et manuel Macron vous avez employé tous
les mots tous les deux le mot de la
dépendance et c'est un sujet qui a
profondément touché les Français après
la publication d'un livre choc il y a
quelques semaines sur les conditions
dans lesquelles nos aînés sont traités
dans les EHPAD la question est simple et
elle s'adresse à l'un et à l'autre
comment faire pour que cela ne se
reproduise jamais Marine Le Pen d'abord
il faut contrôler il faut contrôler
parce qu'il faut contrôler les endroits
où les personnes sont vulnérables voilà
ça c'est une obligation je le crois
deuxièmement il faut imposer un nombre
de personnes minimum et être exigeant
sur ce sujet par rapport au nombre de
résidents il faut à tout prix exiger que
les EHPAD et un médecin coordinateur il
y a encore 30% des EHPAD qui n'ont pas
de médecin coordinateur il faut imposer
qu'il y ait une infirmière 24 heures sur
24 il y a encore une part non
négligeable des EHPAD qui n'ont pas
d'infirmières 24 heures sur 24 et puis
je crois que il faut réfléchir à un
modèle mutualiste des EHPAD les EHPAD
qui font de l'argent sur le dos des
résidents avec des prix qui sont parfois
juste honteux est un modèle qui
évidemment choque les Français et à
juste titre faire de l'argent sur la
durabilité des personnes âgées
c'est quelque chose qui est mal accepté
on le comprend donc il faut encore une
fois réfléchir à un modèle mutualiste
qui m'apparaît beaucoup plus adapté à
côté des EHPAD d'État ce qui est
parfaitement public ce qui est
parfaitement
admissible
un modèle mutualiste pour pouvoir
investir aussi les familles dans les
dans la gestion de ces structures
Emmanuel Macron que proposez-vous
concrètement pour que ce qui a été
dénoncé récemment dans les EHPAD ne se
reproduise plus jamais d'abord je
voudrais corriger d'un point le plan
santé que je développe sur le numerus
clausus d'investissement commence en
2018 donc je n'attends pas la crise
puisque comme vous le savez j'ai été élu
en mai 2017 Ségur
est en juin 2020 mais ce que je veux
dire sur le numérique pour rétablir une
une vérité et cette pandémie nous n'en
avions pas eu depuis un siècle mais se
réinvestissement massif je l'assume et
je veux avancer dans ce sens sur le
avantages d'abord l'immense majorité de
nos compatriotes qui vieillissent
veulent pouvoir vieillir chez eux et je
pense qu'un point important c'est de les
aider à le faire de manière d'abord les
aider à aménager leur logement beaucoup
de nos compatriotes qui nous écoutent
veulent pouvoir être aidés c'est pour ça
que je veux mettre en place un
dispositif ma primadapte qui permettra
d'aménager le logement pour monter les
quelques marches d'accéder aux
sanitaires réaménagé les choses pour
rester à son domicile ensuite il faut
pouvoir
aider celles et ceux qui sont ces
auxiliaires de vie ces aides de vie ces
aides à domicile beaucoup des femmes
souvent qui pour beaucoup d'ailleurs
travaillent sous le salaire minimum
parce qu'elles n'ont pas un salaire
complet parce qu'elles n'ont pas un
temps complétravail à pouvoir avoir les
35 heures ce qui veut dire compléter
leur service et donc dans le
réinvestissement que je veux faire aux
côtés des départements mais c'est prise
en charge par l'État c'est de leur
donner un service complet et permettre
d'avoir plus d'heures par semaine pour
bien s'occuper de nos personnes âgées
chez elles ça rejoint ce que vous avez
dit j'ai entendu moi les mêmes phrases
beaucoup de nos soignants et nos
soignants on ne culpabilise parce que
elle nous disent
je fais pas bien mon travail c'est
quasiment de la maltraitance et le
système les met dans une situation
impossible et donc faut leur donner plus
d'heures parce que c'est pas vrai qu'on
fait la toilette le matin en une
demi-heure c'est pas possible
la deuxième chose c'est qu'il faut
ensuite développer des contrôles et des
moyens il existe déjà des systèmes qui
sont
privés non lucratifs ou mutualistes je
suis totalement favorable je pense qu'il
faut pas jeter le propre sur un système
privé parce que d'abord aussi notre
médecine il y a un système privé il faut
qu'il soit régulé et contrôlé sauf que
jamais l'oublier derrière les patients
et les plus âgés ils sont aidés par la
puissance publique donc il faut
renforcer massivement les contrôles mais
on doit aussi créer plus de poste c'est
pour ça que dans mon projet je propose
50000 postes d'infirmiers infirmières
aide-soignant aide-soignante pourquoi
parce que comme nos compatriotes qui
arrivent en EHPAD
[Musique]
franchement j'imagine vous aurez toute
l'attitude de revenir dessus un thème
qui est même une angoisse pour les
jeunes l'avenir de la planète il y a
quelques jours le GIEC les experts de
l'ONU sur le climat nous ont rappelé que
nous n'avions plus que trois ans pour
limiter à un niveau acceptable les
émissions de gaz effet de serre Marine
Le Pen si vous êtes élu président de la
République quels sont les deux mesures
que vous prendrez en ce sens d'abord
j'arrête l'hypocrisie
qui consiste à refuser de voir que c'est
le modèle économique fondé sur le
libre-échange qui est responsable d'une
grande partie de l'émission des gaz à
effet de serre en France 50% d'ailleurs
donc on ne peut pas sérieusement dire
qu'on va s'attaquer à ce problème en
refusant de regarder que c'est les
importations qui représentent 50% de ces
gaz à effet de serre c'est la raison
pour laquelle je pense que le modèle
économique fondé sur le libre-échange
qui consiste à aller produire à 10000 km
pour consommer 10000 km plus loin est un
modèle qui tue la planète j'ai donc
conçu l'intégralité de mon projet autour
du localisme autour de la relocalisation
des productions et des activités je veux
que l'on puisse créer sur place
consommer au plus près pas tout il y a
des choses qu'on ne pourra pas fabriquer
ou qu'on ne pourra pas cultiver mais au
maximum partir sur leur relocalisation
mais ça veut dire aussi que doit assumer
cette responsabilité et assumer cette
responsabilité c'est mettre en place le
patriotisme économique c'est-à-dire
faire en sorte qu'on arrête par exemple
d'importer la moitié de nos fruits et
légumes alors que nous avons
parfaitement la capacité de pouvoir
répondre à la demande française et c'est
par l'intermédiaire du patriotisme
économique faire en sorte que les
collectivités l'Etat et notamment dans
la restauration collective s'engage à
acheter pabio parce que bio il y a du
bio étranger qui est parfois d'ailleurs
moins dans les normes sont moins
précises et moins sévères que le bio
français non français voilà que l'on
puisse avoir des produits français dans
les cantines collectives de notre pays
ça c'est essentiel et puis je vais vous
dire quand on parle environnement et une
chose dont on parle pas souvent c'est la
souffrance animale pourquoi j'en parle
parce que le libre-échange et le modèle
de libre-échange est un modèle qui est
également fait beaucoup de mal aux
animaux parce que lorsque l'on accepte
des circuits qui fait que on
des bêtes en France qu'on va les
transporter dans des camions dans des
conditions qui sont évidemment
éprouvantes et douloureuses à des
centaines de kilomètres pour aller les
engraisser puis à nouveau à des
centaines de voir des milliers de
kilomètres pour aller les abattre c'est
un modèle qui est un modèle qui est
insensé qui crée du chômage dans notre
pays qui crée de des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre 50%, et qui de surcroît
créé de la souffrance animale et qui
désespèrent en fait nos agriculteurs qui
désespèrent nos industriels parce qu'ils
se retrouvent confrontés en plus à une
concurrence déloyale car il arrive bien
souvent que ces importations ne
respectent pas les normes que nous nous
sommes choisis comme un choix de société
et donc les concurrences directement sur
leur secteur et donc d'abord avant de
parler d'énergie parce que il y a pas un
thème mais avant de parler d'énergie qui
est un élément fondamental on va y venir
il y a le modèle économique à remettre
en cause et puis il y a évidemment des
choix énergétiques dont on a déjà
d'ailleurs on va y venir mais d'abord un
peu parler tout à l'heure le
parallélisme des questions pour Emmanuel
Macron même question pour vous quels
sont les deux engagements que vous vous
engagez à tenir Emmanuel Macron si vous
êtes réélu pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique d'abord ce qui
est intéressant à vous écouter c'est
notre conversation parce que
quand vous parlez de remettre en cause
le modèle de libre-échange et de nos
importations
nos importations qui nous posent le plus
de problèmes et en termes de déficit
commercial que vous évoquez tout à
l'heure et en termes de bilan carbone
c'est notre dépendance aux hydrocarbures
et vous avez proposé la plus grosse
subvention aux hydrocarbures possibles
puisque vous baissez la TVA sur ces
derniers donc je dis juste que votre
programme n'est ni que ni tête cet égard
puisque vous vous proposez une baisse
pérenne comme vous l'avez dit sur les
hydrocarbures énergies fossiles très
polluantes juste par cohérence
moi je considère que là on est sur une
controverse claire j'ai lu votre projet
il est très transparent vous êtes
climato-sceptique
donc c'est net oui vous avez dit
d'ailleurs que avec vous la neutralité
carbone 2050 c'est-à-dire les jalons des
accords de Paris ça ne marche pas moi
j'ai lu j'ai vu j'ai été frappé une fois
encore par le rapport du GIEC et j'ai à
la fois un bilan mais je vais aller
beaucoup plus vite on a doublé le rythme
de réduction de gaz à effet de serre
durant ce quinquennat et lancer une
politique pour la biodiversité je veux
aller deux fois plus vite dans le
quinquennat qui vient c'est pourquoi
première chose que je fais c'est que je
mets un Premier ministre qui est en
charge de cette politique et qui sera en
charge de décliner une planification
énergétique d'une part et une
planification territoriale d'autre part
pour la production des énergies mais
aussi pour la transition ensuite pour
moi la deuxième grande mesure c'est de
continuer à accompagner l'évolution des
grands cycles productifs et de mode de
vie la rénovation thermique des
bâtiments pour la sobriété 700 000
logements par an qu'on peut rénover on
en a fait 650 000 en 2021 j'en veux 700
000 par an sur les 5 années qui viennent
formidable source d'économie d'énergie
et c'est un levier aussi de création
d'emplois pour nos artisans
deuxième chose et dès nos compatriotes à
changer de véhicule et aller vers des
véhicules hybrides ou électriques
produits en France
nous avons tendance quinquennat mi 3 Go
Factory de batterie électrique sur notre
sol dans la région des Hauts-de-France
qui nous échelle et donc développer cela
et puis également accompagner la
transition industrielle comme la
transition agricole pour pouvoir réduire
leurs émissions pas par injonction par
un investissement
Marine Le Pen tête vous voulez répondre
à ce que je viens de dire Emmanuel
Macron oui
absolument pas climato-sceptique
en aucun cas mais vous vous êtes un peu
climato-hypocrite d'ailleurs c'est
peut-être pour ça que les gens ne
croient pas à votre volonté de régler
tous ces problèmes là et je vais vous
dire pourquoi ils ont raison d'ailleurs
c'est que vous êtes en même temps le
pire de l'écologie punitive vous avez
accompagné des choses qui sont d'une
grande violence pour les classes
moyennes pour les classes modestes de
nos compatriotes
toutes les décisions qui ont été prises
qui consiste à expliquer aux gens qui
sont coupables parce qu'ils s'achètent
pas une voiture électrique même s'ils
ont pas les moyens de le faire parce que
le reste à charge
est extrêmement importante toutes les
mesures que vous voulez prendre en leur
disant vous n'aurez plus le droit de
réparer votre chaudière à fioul vous
n'aurez pas le droit de la changer alors
qu'ils n'ont pas les moyens évidemment
de même avec l'aide de l'État de faire
autrement les zones affaiblissement
c'est-à-dire l'Inter qui va être faite
et qui est déjà fait d'ailleurs en
partie aux gens qui ont des voitures
anciennes de pouvoir aller dans les
grandes villes y compris d'ailleurs s'il
y a un hôpital dans cette grande ville
où ils doivent se rendre ils ne pourront
plus s'y rendre tout ça cette écologie
punitive elle est
inutile elle crée encore une fois des
souffrances elle a grave des situations
qui sont des situations de fragilité
d'ores et déjà parce que ça tombe
toujours sur les mêmes c'est toujours
sur ceux qui ont pas les moyens vous le
savez bien ceux qui ont les moyens n'ont
pas ce genre de problème donc ça moi je
suis je suis profondément en désaccord
avec cela oui à la transition bien sûr
il faut qu'il y ait une transition mais
il faut qu'elle soit évidemment dans le
temps beaucoup moins rapide que ce qu'on
impose aux Français pour permettre pour
leur permettre de pouvoir de pouvoir y
faire face ça c'est une c'est une
évidence et puis la deuxième des choses
c'est vos changements de pieds quand
même vous avez sur l'énergie qui est
pourtant un élément structurant quand
même de l'avenir d'un pays l'énergie et
notamment l'indépendance et le choix
d'une énergie décarbonée qui est
nucléaire vous avez complètement changé
d'avis vous avez démarré votre mandat en
expliquant en fermant ces name en
fermant Fessenheim alors qu'aucune
justification de sécurité
ne le permettait tout le monde et toutes
les structures disaient que en terme de
sûreté de sécurité il y avait aucune
difficulté avec ça vous l'avez fermé
vous avez envisagé de fermer 14
réacteurs nucléaires vous avez arrêté à
Street et puis à la fin de votre mandat
vous vous dites je me suis trompé bah
oui vous êtes peut-être trompé mais le
problème c'est que vous étiez aussi
trompé quand vous étiez avec aux côtés
de François Hollande ça fait qu'on a
perdu 10 ans à déstabiliser une filière
nucléaire qui avait besoin d'être
renforcée qui avait besoin d'être
soutenu qui avait besoin de visibilité
dans l'avenir pour pouvoir faire de
cette outil décarbonée et qui nous
permet d'être indépendant à nouveau un
socle pour notre mix énergétique c'est
extrêmement regrettable vous avez fait
le choix par ailleurs des éoliens de
l'éolienne par et du solaire l'éolien
étant le pire
et puisque il est en même temps une
absurdité écologique une absurdité
économique une
jeune fondamentale pour la biodiversité
une un choix qui fait baisser le prix
des biens immobiliers qui sont à
proximité enfin qui est alternative donc
elle fonctionne évidemment quand il y a
du vent quand il y a pas de vent elle
fonctionne pas et quand elles ne
fonctionnent pas et bien elle fait
fonctionner des centrales à gazou à
charbon justement compenser donc vous
avez vous n'aviez pas de vision dans ce
domaine et je crois que vous avez mis la
France en grande difficulté vous avez
sur ce thème là d'énergie qui nous
intéresse tous beaucoup de 3 minutes
d'avance Emmanuel Macron Marine Le Pen a
mentionnait il y a un instant à la fin
des fins vous êtes plutôt d'accord sur
la politique concernant le l'énergie
nucléaire grande différence en revanche
concernant les éoliennes dans son
programme Marine Le Pen voulait démanter
et ne pas en construire de neuves vous
vous êtes plutôt en faveur des éoliennes
surtout les éoliennes en mer c'est cela
oui bon d'abord
pas un mot sur l'écologie dansant 22
mesures pour la France il y a un livret
et d'ailleurs qui est assez édifiant
donc je vais y revenir parce que il dit
très clairement ce que ce que j'évoquais
à l'instant d'abord quand j'ai été
ministre de l'Économie des Finances je
peux pas vous laisser dire ce que vous
avez dit puisque je me suis occupé de la
restructuration du secteur nucléaire qui
était en train de s'effondrer et je
pense à tous les tous les salariés tous
les ouvriers de ce secteur à tous les
savoir-faire qu'on a on l'a sauvé grâce
au vaisseau amiral EDF qui a fait un
travail formidable et aussi
restructuration qu'on a qu'on a réussi à
faire à ce moment-là ensuite Fessenheim
j'assume totalement madame le penal est
plus un investissement depuis 2012
c'était la plus vieille en circuit qui
était en service et il n'y avait plus
d'investissement depuis 2012 et donc
quand on voit les difficultés qu'on a
sur le parc installé avec les
investissements que j'ai décidé dès le
début du quinquennat
de grands carénages la rentabilité de ce
projet n'était plus du tout au
rendez-vous et donc il était devenu
pertinent d'aller au bout et mettre
compenser le territoire et la transition
j'assume d'avoir fermé et on a réussi en
quasi-totalité le retard sur le père de
Flamanville nous a pas permis de le
faire en totalité nos centrales
thermiques nous en avions fallait
prendre la décision fallait le courage
d'aller expliquer aux gens
et d'est en ouest de Saint-Avold
au Havre ailleurs nous l'avons fait
parce que nous avons fait cette
transition pour justement moins émettre
donc on a une j'ai eu pendant ces cinq
ans une vraie stratégie une vraie
volonté et j'ai reposé dès 2018 le sujet
de la baisse du nucléaire qui avait été
voté en 2015 j'ai reposé en demandant à
l'Agence internationale de l'énergie et
à RTE
de me faire une analyse quand elle m'a
été rendue je l'ai suivi il dit très
clairement d'abord que le programme qui
est le vôtre est intenable puisque je
vous renvoie ce rapport d'experts et
d'ailleurs ça correspond à ce que tous
les experts indépendants y compris du
GIEC et d'ailleurs disent il n'y a pas
de stratégie de sortie des énergies
fossiles qui ne passent par le tout
nucléaire votre stratégie tu stratégie
du tout nucléaire elle n'est pas
possible et vous ne pouvez pas remplacer
y compris le renouvelable actuel que
vous voulez démonter par du nucléaire
car le nucléaire qu'on décide
aujourd'hui il entrera en service en
2035 Madame Le Pen
donc le temps il connaît pas ne nous
rend pas dans une situation on peut
remplacer l'un par l'autre il faut faire
les deux là aussi pardon de la référence
aux auteurs en même temps c'est
d'ailleurs exactement la conclusion de
ce rapport c'est pourquoi j'ai décidé à
la lumière de ce rapport un programme de
nouvelles tranches de pairs 6 8 mais
surtout d'investir dans le renouvelable
de se donner plus de temps sur l'éolien
terrestre c'est pour ça que j'ai divisé
par deux le rythme par rapport à ce qui
était prévu initialement pour le donner
à 2050 comme horizon mais de développer
le solaire le petit solaire dans nos
ruralités s'est demandé la
grivevoltaïsme est un vrai projet que
veulent porter nos agriculteurs s'il est
raisonné et on va le faire avec eux et
ce qu'on veut aussi faire c'est l'éolien
en mer pourquoi parce que ça crée de
l'emploi votre projet en effet proposez
vous de stopper mais de les démonter
vous allez démanteler les éoliennes qui
existent ce qui coûte un argent fou et
donc je trouve que l'argent du
contribuable pour être mieux utilisé ce
d'autant que dans toutes ces filières
nous créons l’emploi en France quand on
fait de l'éolien en mer on crée de
l'emploi j'étais au Havre dans une usine
la semaine dernière ou en France nous
produisons les pales l'ensemble des
infrastructures pour ces éoliennes en
mer convaincre qu'on va ainsi développer
faut concerter avec les pêcheurs avec
l'ensemble des usages se qu'on fait faut
aller plus vite sur nos projets mais
faut pouvoir le développer le seul moyen
de répondre aux défis climatiques c'est
de faire
l'énergie renouvelable et du nucléaire
mais il faut faire les deux simplement
faut pas refaire les erreurs du passé il
faut pouvoir développer des filières
industrielles dans notre pays comme j'ai
commencé à le faire durant ces cinq
années de la batterie électrique
jusqu'aux éoliennes et comme je veux
continuer de le faire bien on vous
mettra pas d'accord sur cette question
là non je vous laisse répondre
mais rapidement s'il vous plaît si vous
voulez
concertation avec les pêcheurs moi je
les ai tous rencontrés ils sont tous
ventes debout évidemment
de la pêche
3000 je crois que vous voulez en mettre
partout sur toutes les côtes sauf en
face du Touquet parce qu'il faut quand
même pas non plus
Madame Le Pen pousser mais je tiens à
vous dire et à dire à ceux qui nous
écoutent que le début c'est la réalité
je suis désolé de vous le dire
tous ont été tous ont été actés sur ce
lieu en face du Touquet mais vous
rigolez le démantèlement des éoliennes
le démantèle la planification
le démantèlement des éoliennes et
cautionnement de leur installation
auprès non c'est le hasard auprès des
dépôts
j'ai toujours dit que j'allais engager
le chantier du démantèlement mais je
vais engager le chantier
d'éventuellement déjà il y en a 2000 qui
vont arriver en bout de course et en
bout de course et bien ce n'est pas
l'état qui paye le démantèlement ce sont
mais c'est l'exploitant qui démantèle et
c'est cautionné et vous le savez très
bien cautionner auprès de la Caisse des
dépôts en revanche ce que je
démantèlerai c'est ce des éoliennes qui
représentent un trouble anormaux du
voisinage et il y en a de plus en plus
et de plus en plus d'ailleurs de
tribunaux qui constatent ces troubles
anormaux du voisinage et bien on
commencera par celle-là et puis vous
fera des référendums on demandera la vie
aux gens je sais que vous n'aimez pas
bien ça mais moi j'aime beaucoup ça
demander la vie
solliciterais pour leur demander s'il
souhaite élémenteler on va engager ce
chantier là parce que encore une fois ça
coûte très cher aux Français ça pollue
nos paysages c'est intermittent on
s'appuie sur du gaz et du charbon et ça
n'est vraiment pas la bonne solution
alors que nous avons l'hydroélectricité
sur lequel nous pouvons évidemment nous
appuyer dans notre mix énergétique et
nous aurons je l'espère demain de plus
en plus de l'hydrogène vert que
d'ailleurs je je on le fait comment
l'hydrogène vert avec de du nucléaire
donc l'hydrogène vert comme vous allez
supprimer des capacités de renouvelables
on le fait on a négocié la France s'est
battue votre serviteur avec le avec le
crâne nucléaire avec du nucléaire à
venir parce qu'aujourd'hui le nucléaire
il est pas pour faire il est pas fait
pour faire l'hydrogène il est fait pour
nous chauffer donc vous avec votre
stratégie vous ne pourrez pas faire de
pour développer le nucléaire mais vous
n'arriverez pas à ouvrir des centrales
avant 2035 Madame Le Pen dès le début de
mon mandat et vous avez le temps
industriel Madame Le Pen vous vous en
déplaise donc vous ne pourrez pas
produire vous savez moi je ne suis pas
comme vous moi je ne ferme pas fait ça
c'est vrai je ne ferme pas fait ce name
en sachant je vous remercie que ça
risque de nous poser des problèmes de
production vous voyez donc j'engagerai
le chantier en fonction et notamment en
attendant que Flamanville soit mis en en
fonctionnement et à ce moment-là on
démarrera ce chantier de démantèlement
je crois les Français l'hydrogène n'est
pas une source d'énergie j'ai bien
compris non mais je vous le dis parce
que donc j'ai parlé du mixe non mais
donc c'est pas une source d'énergie pour
faire de l'hydrogène en particulier vers
ou peu polluant parce qu'on est
terminologie dépend avec le nucléaire il
faut ou du nucléaire nous nous sommes
battus pour l'obtenir ou du renouvelable
bon si vous vous stoppez le renouvelable
on va produire moins d'électricité
de fait et donc alors même qu'on a des
besoins aujourd'hui vous ne m'expliquez
pas comment on va faire face pour nous
passer l'hydrocarbure pour baisser notre
dépendance au gaz russe aux énergies
fossiles puisque vous vous détruisez
pendant des années des capacités à
produire de l'électricité avec le
renouvelable et de manière progressive
en fonction de nos nouveaux nucléaire il
ne commencera pas avant 2035 j'ai décidé
si tranche à Belfort elles ouvriront en
2035 au dire même de DF
en 2023 un petit point je ne suis pas le
technicien mais ça c'est déjà dans nos
chiffres mais dis-moi
une autre stratégie elle ne boucle pas
Emmanuel et d'ailleurs il y a aucun
manuel Macron Marine Le Pen est appuyé
sur une vision Emmanuel Macron
vous êtes à parfaite égalité Léa alors
on va passer on va avancer parce qu'il y
a encore beaucoup de sujets à que ce
soit vous voulez notamment parler de la
sécurité de l'immigration de la
gouvernance de comment gouverne notre
pays et comment vous voulez changer les
choses mais il y a un sujet
l'attractivité de la France est un sujet
où nous sommes en retard sur les
nouvelles technologies et notamment
l'économie numérique Amazon Apple Google
sont aujourd'hui américain Tic-Toc et
chinois comment faire pour avoir demain
un Google français un Steve Jobs
français vous avez la parole Marine Le
Pen déjà la première des choses qu'on
aurait pu faire parce que vous voyez
autant l'Union européenne se mette
absolument tout y compris de ce qu'il a
regardé pas et impose parfois des
directives qui sont contraires à nos
intérêts vitaux et contre un autre
sécurité
contre un même à nos intérêts
économiques autant là le Google européen
ça fait des années qu'en réalité il
aurait dû être lancé ça fait des années
que on aurait dû avoir une réflexion sur
comment est-ce qu'on met en place le
moyen de conserver les prenez sur le
territoire européen comment est-ce qu'on
arrive à créer je sais que c'est pas non
plus donné ils ont pris beaucoup
d'avance sur sur nous c'est dommage
d'ailleurs parce que on nous étions
grâce à nos ingénieurs très en avance
dans ces domaines-là
je pense qu'il faut que on crée au
niveau européen de la même manière qu'on
a créé une comment dire une
politique spatiale on a fait Arbus on a
fait Ariane il faudrait qu'on fasse
évidemment un Google européen et comme
moi on mette en place les moyens de
préserver nos données mais pour
l'instant les tentatives en tout cas
n'ont pas été couronnés de succès
Emmanuel Macron pourquoi sont-ils
américains
euh chinois et pourquoi Steve Jobs
était-il américain et pas français alors
d'abord je veux défendre la force de la
France nos entrepreneurs parce que notre
pays est celui qui produit le plus de
start-up en Europe qui ont développé le
plus et ses startups
qui dépasse le milliard de chiffres
d'affaires valorisation et
laissons aujourd'hui près de 25 et elles
vont continuer à
accroître et d'ailleurs elle nous
apporte des services de blablacar
adoctolib on l'a vécu pendant la crise
donc on peut être fière et doctolib a
aidé aux solutions d'ailleurs y compris
en Allemagne pendant la pandémie donc on
a des vrais champions simplement la
différence qui entre la Chine les
États-Unis on en revient à notre vision
différente que j'assume
c'est que la France n'est pas l'Europe
et que les États-Unis c'est un marché de
près de 400 millions de personnes la
Chine c'est un marché d'un milliard la
France c'est un marché de 65 millions
d'habitants si on veut faire des
champions faut que le marché domestique
tout de suite ce soit le marché de
l'Union européenne donc faut un vrai
marché unique du numérique faut pas
qu'il y ait de barrière et donc qui
n'aime pas l'Europe ben ne peut pas
développer des champions du numérique
c'est clair j'ai pourquoi parce que
c'est pas l'Europe qui décide de le
faire Google n'a pas été créé par un
gouvernement ça a été créé par des
entrepreneurs ils ont eu parfois des
programmes qui les ont aidés comme nous
d'ailleurs nous ont développons mais il
faut surtout qu'il y ait un marché qui
fonctionne qui permet d'avancer la
deuxième chose il faut protéger nos
citoyens l'Europe là aussi a créé les
premiers standards pour nous donner
individuelles le rgpd pour donner le
l'acronyme mais qui est le règlement
général pour la protection justement des
données sur nos vies privées c'est
l'Europe qui la mise en place l'Europe
nous protège qu'en tant que citoyen elle
doit aller plus loin c'est ce qui doit
nous permettre on n'y est pas encore
d'avoir justement le nuage dans lesquels
on va pouvoir stocker ses données même
quand c'est des acteurs américains pour
mieux les contrôler et donc moi je crois
complètement à la possibilité de bâtir
une France 2030 une Europe 2030 de
l'innovation de la transformation par le
numérique mais on décrêtera pas ces
champions faut bien les former c'est
pour ça que nous en France il faut avoir
une politique de formation d'excellence
académique et d'investissement dans la
recherche comme on a commencé à le faire
sur laquelle je veux investir sur 10 ans
il faut ensuite qu'en Europe on
développe cela qu'on est des grands
programmes de recherche européen comme
on a commencé à le faire mais qu'on est
un marché européen qui permette d'avoir
la même rapidité la même force que les
grands marchés américains et chinois je
crois qu'on aborde ensemble vous parliez
de après il faut pouvoir réguler les
compétiteurs et donc il faut aussi une
politique européenne qui se bat contre
la concurrence déloyale et c'est là où
l'Europe nous est
utile quand les Google viennent nous
attaquer sur nos marchés qui nous aident
l'Europe et quand ces grands groupes ne
payent pas l'impôt chez nous qu'est-ce
qui peut nous permettre d'y répondre
l'Europe c'est le combat que la France
même depuis quatre ans il faut le dire à
mon initiative nous avons d'abord eu un
blocage européen on nous a renvoyé à
l'international on a fini par convaincre
les Américains sous président françaises
on va mettre cette impôt minimale de 15%
pour tous les groupes qui font du profit
chez nous Marine Le Pen vous avez 15
secondes un peu plus 30 secondes pour
répondre quand je vous dois dire
l'Europe l'Europe je pense au mot du
général de Gaulle Madame Le Pen nous
venons vous ne devriez pas parler du
général de Gaulle
n'était pas l'origine d'Ariane l'Union
européenne n'était pas l'origine
d'Airbus voilà oh non mais c'est pour
vous dire que vous avez raison c'est
l'amitié francophone qui était à
l'origine d'Airbus cette amitié
franco-allemande dont vous avez dit la
semaine dernière que vous voulez vous en
séparer
c'est pas non mais je veux dire là il se
trouve que sur ce sujet là oui bien
entendu
l'Europe et l'espace qui se justifie
mais en espèce c'est européenne voyez
vous faites toujours la confusion entre
l'Union européenne et l'Europe voilà
l'Europe c'est l'Europe on aime je suis
Européenne j'ai aucun problème avec ça
j'adore ce continent les pays européens
aucun souci l'Union européenne c'est une
structure politique donc ça c'est pas
nous avons créé deuxièmement on parlait
de l'innovation on parlait d'entreprise
mais on peut aussi parler des autres
voilà c'était la question je modestement
répondu à la question que j'ai posé
le problème c'est que aujourd'hui le
problème de notre économie me
semble-t-il et qui est aussi d'ailleurs
le problème du financement de nos
retraites d'après ce que dit Conseil
d'orientation des retraites c'est le
problème de l'absence de hausse de
productivité dont je parlais tout à
l'heure et pourquoi parce qu'en fait on
est dans une économie qui est en train
de superiser c'est à dire que on crée
des emplois mais on crée des emplois qui
sont des emplois à très bas coût qui
sont des emplois qui sont très précaires
ce sont des emplois de gens qui vont sur
mobylette avec beaucoup de courage
d'ailleurs il faut bien dire bien
souvent pour porter des repas c'est ça
les emplois qu'on a concret aujourd'hui
et je pense que c'est une erreur
fondamentale et qu'avec des emplois
comme ça par définition de crêpes de
richesse si on ne crée pas de richesse
et bien on ne peut rien financer
d'ailleurs ni notre système de
protection sociale ni les développements
nécessaires donc je pense qu'il faut
faire un effort évidemment considérable
sur l'industrie c'est sur l'industrie
qui a un effort à faire et l'effort je
le crois n'a pas en espèces a été fait
et puis Marine Le Pen parle si vous
voulez moi j'essaye de mettre à la place
des gens et rapidement
qu'on parle de Google européen etc il y
a des gens qui nous regardent ils ont
toujours ils sont toujours dans un
espace où ils ont pas la fibre ou
bien ils n'ont pas de couverture
numérique donc je pense que ça pourrait
peut-être la première des priorités car
en plus nous aurons besoin de cette
couverture numérique parfaite sur le
territoire parce que si on veut faire de
la télémédecine si on veut faire de la
téléconsultation si on veut faire toutes
ces choses là qui sont des nouvelles
technologies on pourra jamais le faire
si on est encore dans des espaces où la
couverture numérique est pour le moins
défaillante voilà vous parliez des
inventions du nom un instant vous
parliez des inventions du jour de
l'économie de la productivité j'aurais
qu'on parle de l'intelligence de demain
de nos enfants de la formation de
l'éducation de la jeunesse tous les
classements internationaux montrent
encore et encore que le niveau de
connaissance des élèves français baisse
un seul exemple vous le connaissez le
fameux classement PISA montre que le
classement de nos élèves français en
mathématiques abaissées ils étaient 12e
il y a 20 ans ils sont 26e aujourd'hui
Emmanuel Macron si vous êtes réélu
président de la République comment
ferez-vous pour éviter pour stopper ce
décrochage bon d'abord c'est dommage
qu'on n'ait pas poursuivre sur notre
agriculture qui est en effet un secteur
ce sont les essentiels et sur notre
industrie parce que sous ce quinquennat
pour la première fois depuis plus de 15
ans on a industrialiser on a créé plus
d'emplois qu'on en a détruit on a
surtout ouvert plus d'usines qu'on en a
fermé Madame Le Pen et c'est aussi le
fruit des réformes que j'ai conduites et
auxquelles vous vous êtes opposé
intégralement donc
aux chiffres sont faux et les chiffres
de l'INSEE le montrent très bien c'est
indépendant mais les ordonnances
travaillent ont permis de simplifier les
choses vous les maintiendrez d'ailleurs
si vous étiez
oui ou non je suis absolument
scandalisé par la manière dont vous avez
fait passer tout ça avec brutalité vous
reviendriez sur un sujet non vous savez
ce que je ferais je ferai une grande
conférence sociale à l'automne avec les
syndicats pour parler enfin avec eux
sentiment absolument comme tous les
corps intermédiaires d'ailleurs d'être
totalement méprisé les emplois
industriels si on a sauvé les emplois
industriels pendant la crise
et objectivement les ordonnances travail
ils n'ont évidemment et cette assez
naturel mal pris de la même manière
qu'ils ont assez mal pris la réforme que
vous avez faite de l'indemnisation du
chômage qu'il l'a encore a touché les
plus pauvres madame
attractivité ben moi j'ai pas la même
emploi quand on oui vous avez raison de
ne pas avoir la même vision que moi et
de bien le dire parce que quand on crée
un million 200 000 emplois qu'on crée de
l'emploi industriel on lutte
véritablement quand on la pauvreté
mais je voudrais simplement vous dire ne
convoquez pas ici les partenaires
sociaux ils ont encore dit à quelques
jours tous qui ne voulaient pas
travailler avec vous
la CGT et c'est parce que j'ai réuni les
partenaires sociaux qu'ils ont été
autour de la table des responsables que
pendant la crise covid ils vont pas être
très content que vous les appelez pour
le coup là Madame Le Pen Emmanuel
un système de chômage partiel qui a
protégé nos emplois l'industrie on l'a
fait comme ça
si nous étions maître d'école ce que
nous ne sommes pas vous ne vous dirions
vous n'êtes pas obligé
je vous en prie revenons à l'école
comment éviter de faire revenir sur
comment éviter de décrocher le
décrochage unanimement constaté de nos
élèves en France
d'abord on a commencé à le faire
puisque l'investissement qui a été fait
en CPCE 1 pour les plus petites classes
donc ils ne sont pas prises en compte
encore dans les fameux tests PISA qui ne
sont faits qu'au collège a permis et ça
on le mesure puisqu'on avait remis en
place les tests annuels pour les enfants
de la République qui sont les plus en
difficulté et bien de rattraper parce
qu'on a fait des classes plus petites on
a mis deux élèves par classe ce que je
veux faire c'est continuer à investir
sur notre école les fondamentaux en
remettant les mathématiques jusque au
baccalauréat c'est là où je veux changer
la réforme que nous avons fait ensuite
en y mettant la demi-heure de sport
quotidienne qui est un point très
important y compris pour mieux apprendre
et le sport à l'école est un point
fondamental pour l'apprentissage en
développant l'éducation artistique et
culturelle qui est aux côtés des savoirs
fondamentaux est un projet pour l'école
à mes yeux décisifs ensuite c'est de
mettre les moyens sur les classes de
sixième et de seconde qui sont les
classes charnières ou les décrochages se
font là aussi en permettant partout où
c'est nécessaire de dédoubler ensuite
c'est d'améliorer l'orientation dès la
cinquième en permettant quoi pas du tout
de mettre les gens dans une filière de
nos collégiens pas du tout mais en leur
permettant au collège d'avoir accès à
des métiers à l'extérieur
d'être ouvert au reste du monde pour
comprendre ce vers quoi ils veulent
aller aider à l'orientation parce que
c'est un des drames qu'à notre jeunesse
aujourd'hui puis je veux mener une
grande réforme du lycée professionnel
parce que il y a un tiers de nos
médecins qui sont au lycée professionnel
les stagiaires ne sont pas payés ce qui
était un scandale aujourd'hui je vais
pouvoir les payer je vais pouvoir
m'inspirer du vrai succès de ce
quinquennat en la matière qui est celui
de l'apprentissage quand j'ai été élu il
y avait moins de 300 000 apprentis
chaque année il y en a aujourd'hui plus
de 710 000 et nous avons fait une
réforme avec les branches
professionnelles forts de celle-ci je
veux réformer le lycée professionnel et
puis aller vers une réforme de
l'université en ouvrant des filières là
aussi avec des débouchés plus clairs en
continuant d'aider nos étudiants études
gratuites on va continuer ce qu'on a
fait sur la baisse justement des
mutuelles et de la sécurité sociale
étudiante et en accompagnant mieux en
particulier sur le sur le logement mais
surtout sujet
profondément différente sur la santé
comme sur l'école je veux une méthode où
les grands objectifs seront fixés
nationalement mais où on déclinera
ensuite localement les voies et moyens
d'y arriver avec une manière claire on
ira au bout de la revalorisation
commencée pour les professeurs à qui
nous devons tant parce qu'on a rouvert
l'école grâce à eux et donc on va tous
les revaloriser comme on a commencé de
le faire mais on revalorisera très
substantiellement celles et ceux qui
iront jusqu'à 20% celles et ceux qui
vont sur les méthodes qui sont les plus
innovantes et en permettant plus de
liberté justement sur le terrain à nos
prophètes vous avez anticipé notre
question sur l'augmentation des
professeurs mais du coup vous allez
pouvoir répondre aux deux questions
d'abord comment on fait pour revenir
parmi les premiers dans les classements
internationaux pour arrêter ce
décrochage de nos élèves et ensuite si
vous le souhaitez dire si vous augmentez
ou pas les enseignants si vous êtes
président d'abord pour vous dire que
la jeunesse française a tellement
souffert tellement souffert dans les
deux dernières années de dernières
années et demi
privée lien sociaux un privé de leur
famille bien souvent
privé de leur petit boulot donc je t'ai
dans la précarité
développant des problèmes psychologiques
pour certains lourds parce qu'ils ont
très très mal vécu évidemment la crise
sanitaire que c'était une évidence pour
moi qu'il fallait que je fasse de la
jeunesse la priorité d'un quinquennat si
les Français me font cette confiance et
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
construit autour de la jeunesse
énormément effectivement d'être de
mesures et notamment autour de la valeur
travail je vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure
je veux revaloriser les filières
professionnelles
l'alternance l'apprentissage
monsieur Macron vous avez d'ailleurs
fait mais c'est toujours provisoire
c'est toujours transitoire c'est jamais
pérenne moi ce sera pérenne mais vous
aviez fait quelque chose qui est positif
de l'apprentissage est pérenne madame
qui était pérenne mais moi ce que je
veux c'est aussi augmenter
il est revenu en fait de ces apprentis
et de ses alternants donc ils auront 200
à 300 euros par mois en fonction de leur
âge bon ça c'est la première des choses
deuxièmement je souhaite que les
étudiants qui travaillent soient aidés
je pense qu'il faut qu'ils aient un
complément de salaire parce que ceux qui
travaillent et bien ils sont courageux
parce qu'après tout faire des études et
travailler c'est pas facile et pouvoir
faire en sorte de leur accorder 20% de
leur salaire jusqu'à 200 euros ou 30%
jusqu'à 300 euros pour les boursiers et
ben je trouve que c'est évidemment
extrêmement important je souhaite aussi
qu'ils puissent voyager qui puisse
trouver un emploi et donc je suis pour
la gratuité aux heures creuses de train
même des grandes lignes d'ailleurs pour
les 18-25 ans mais ce qui a été aussi
terrible pendant cette crise sanitaire
c'est qu'en fait ils ont eu des diplômes
qui ont été dévalorisés et de manière
générale d'ailleurs les diplômes sont
dévalorisés et parce que d'abord le
baccaréat est dévalorisé donc je veux
refaire du baccalauréat un examen on
détermine pas à l'avance si on va donner
à 95% ou à 98% de la classe d'âge parce
que je pense qu'on ne rend pas service
en réalité à nos jeunes deuxièmement je
souhaite le retour de filière littéraire
scientifique économique et je souhaite
bien entendu faire un effort tout
particulier sur les savoirs fondamentaux
en primaire parce que c'est
effectivement là que tout se joue et je
voudrais aborder un sujet que Monsieur
Macron n'a pas abordé ces sujets de la
sécurité à l'école de la discipline et
puis du respect des professeurs parce
que la la réforme que vous proposez est
une réforme qui consiste à payer les
professeurs en fonction des résultats de
leurs élèves je sais pas c'est making
c'est qui a proposé ça mais
du temps Madame
je pense que ça peut être ça peut être
là franchement pour le coup ça peut être
eux je trouve que c'est profondément
injuste car vous savez très bien que
selon l'endroit où les professeurs
professent où ils enseignent et bien les
niveaux des élèves ne sont pas toujours
le même j'ai accordé donc de 4000 euros
à tous les professeurs qui sont en
repérer plus ça veut dire que demain
vous souhaitez et ils sont très
mécontents et ils ont raison d'ailleurs
ce que vous souhaitez c'est en réalité
les pays en fonction des résultats de la
réalité et puis en fonction de ce qui
serait capable de faire à côté
d'ailleurs de l'école moi je souhaite
les revaloriser je le dis je souhaite
les revaloriser de 3% par an en les
faisant travailler
16%, non car ils seront payés en plus
pour cette demi-journée au primaires le
mercredi matin non je ne joue pas ce
genre de choses moi et donc
elles ont été budgétées et donc ça
permettra si vous voulez d'avoir des
élèves qui sortent qui arrivent en
sixième en maîtrisant la la langue
française ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui car il y a 20% des élèves
qui ne maîtrisent pas les savoirs
fondamentaux et ça c'est évidemment
catastrophique mais ce dont vous n'avez
pas parlé c'est la sécurité à l'école
parce que aujourd'hui il y a des classes
entières qui sont
persécutés avec leur professeur
d'ailleurs par quelques individus que
qu'on laisse nuire à l'ensemble de la
classe qu'on laisse gâcher l'avenir de
certains élèves qui du coup n'arrivent
pas à travailler parce que la
transmission du savoir ça se fait dans
la tranquillité dans la paix dans le
respect du professeur et je pense qu'il
faut être beaucoup plus sévère je pense
qu'il faut arrêter de mettre la
poussière sous le tapis d'arrêter de ne
pas de vagues dans beaucoup de
professeurs se sont plein d'ailleurs et
qui fait que on ne prend plus de
décisions que le Conseil de Discipline
n'ose plus prendre de sanctions
d'exclusions y compris d'exclusion
définitives je le dis quitte à ouvrir
encore une fois des internats qui soient
spécifiques à ces enfants qui ont des
problèmes de délinquance de problèmes de
comportement mais qui ne doivent pas
empêcher les autres de réussir voilà ce
que je crois moi je crois beaucoup à
l'école je crois à l'assimilation
républicaine je crois que le rôle de
l'école comme
creusait
républicain et fondamental et c'est tout
cela aussi qu'il faut sauver et tout
cela aussi qui est en train de
disparaître aujourd'hui Emmanuel Macron
votre réponse sur la revanche la valeur
de l'école et les conditions de sécurité
des enseignants à commencer sous ce
quinquennat
elle conduira et je veux la poursuivre
et la poursuivre dès le début si les
Françaises et les Françaises me font
confiance qui fait que manière
inconditionnelle il y a une
revalorisation d'environ 10% de nos
enseignants il fait qu'il y aura plus de
prix en particulier démarrage de
carrière sous 2000 euros donc je vais le
dire ici très clairement et ces
conditionné à absolument rien déjà
première en 2017 mais ça doit pas être
le cas Madame Le Pen elle a été
commencée et vos 3% ne permettront pas
d'y arriver mais vaut 3% ne permettront
pas d'y arriver Madame Le Pen donc et
moi c'est sans demi-journée plus parce
que 16% de plus à la fin du quinquiète
donc alors c'est plus 3% c'est 3% par an
alors c'est pas du tout ce que vous avez
financé si en plus vous rembauchez
j'espère qu'on pourra parler quand même
du financement des projets parce que oui
à travers tout ça avec vos 600 milliards
je suis sûr que vous êtes absolument
complètement les 600 milliards d'euros
de dettes on peut se la refaire 10 fois
oui on peut c'est pas du financement
courant c'est de la dette covid qui a
aidé nos compatriotes qui nous écoutent
et en particulier dans cette période
c'est pour ça que parlant de l'école je
veux ici le redire qui nous a permis de
maintenir l'école ouverte ce que moi je
n'oublie pas les deux ans et demi non
plus nous venons de vivre la solitude de
nos enfants est le fait que pour
beaucoup de quartiers de la République
quand les parents allaient faire tourner
l'économie
celles et ceux qui font partie
des corvées des grandes difficultés de
notre République et bien si nous
n'avions pas rouvert l'école grâce à nos
enseignants je sais que vous vous êtes
au combien en poser à cette mesure dès
le 11 mai 2020 n'aurions pas de pu
parfois servir un repas par jour à ses
enfants et leur permettre d'avoir une
année justement des plus corrects et
quand je regarde les choses parce que
nous venons de vivre une pandémie comme
nous n'en avions jamais vécu dans le
siècle grâce à l'investissement de la
nation la politique que nous avons
conduite ce que nos enseignants ont fait
on a permis de continuer à former nos
enfants et nos adolescents et quand je
regarde les résultats on a évité des
drames comme ils se sont passés aux
États-Unis ou dans d'autres pays
européens qui parfois ont fermé 25 30 35
semaines nous ne l'avons pas fait et
donc moi je suis attaché à cette école
ouverte à cette école
française cette école de la République
et donc c'est pourquoi les enseignants
contrairement à ce que vous avez dit
font l'objet d'une revalorisation mais
elle est inconditionnelle mais je veux
aussi leur donner de liberté sur le
terrain je veux aussi reconnaître le
fait que ils ont besoin d'avoir plus de
liberté pour travailler avec les parents
d'élèves avec les directrices et
directeurs d'école avec celles et ceux
qui font le périscolaire comme on a
commencé à le faire parce que quand on
vient d'un quartier difficile que les
parents n'ont pas de bibliothèque que on
n'est pas aidé à la maison
on a beau parler d'école de la
République mais l'injustice recommence à
17h chaque jour et chaque week-end et
donc là il faut que l'école puisse
réinvestir avec toutes les parties
prenantes le problème le problème
monsieur Macron c'est que on a
l'impression que dans votre vision tout
s'arrête en fait aux grandes villes pas
du tout les quartiers difficiles
vous l'avez réservé pour les quartiers
difficiles les taux d'encadrement de
l'école primaire
à l'ensemble de la France Emmanuel
ensemble des enfants français qui pour
pouvoir redresser cette école primaire
qui effectivement fait que
elle ne remplit plus son rôle et que on
s'effondre dans l'intégralité des
classements là encore vous êtes un peu
confus vous avez supprimé les
mathématiques vous les avez rétablis
et défait
d'accord mais ça démontre quand même un
problème de vision le sur le principe le
dédoublement des CP CE1 vous ne pouvez
pas le faire France entière c'est
impossible et n'essayez pas de poser les
villes aux champs c'est des quartiers
les plus pauvres de la République en
repérer plus dans lequel nous l'avons
fait mais je vous invite à regarder dans
nos ruralités auxquelles je tiens tant
et pour lesquels de la fibre à la
réouverture des petites lignes de chemin
de fer au retour des services publics
nous avons tant fait durant ces
dernières années dans nos ruralités
vous ne vivez que de la peur Madame Le
Pen et que du ressentiment je le sais
moi j'essaie de parler de la musique
et que je je pense
par classe c'est là où il est le plus
faible dans nos ruralités
la fermeture des classes sans l'accord
du maire ça n'est pas vrai
des écoles
vous le savez Emmanuel Macron il faut
pas dire ça parce que pour le coup il y
a des millions de gens qui nous écoutent
j'ai des millions de gens qui savent que
il y a une clairement dans l'école à
chaque fois ça c'est fait leur vie
moyenne à chaque fois il y a une
consultation du maire ce qui n'était
jamais le cas avant et ça c'est depuis
2019 Emmanuel parce que je suis attaché
à l'école de la République vous savez
j'en viens à Madame Le Pen moi aussi
Emmanuel Macron et des
anciens Marine Le Pen s'il vous plaît
bon vous êtes à peu près parfait là
c'est moi qui vous félicite sur le
chronomètre vous êtes à non mais
on tient autant vous les tenez en tout
cas voilà là vous avez mes félicitations
on va passer au thème un thème qui est
également une des priorités des Français
vous en avez légèrement esquissé Marine
Le Pen à l'instant la question de la
sécurité des Français vous garantissez
ce soir Marine Le Pen devant les
millions de Français qui nous regardent
qu'avec vous à la tête de la France il y
aura moins de violence dans la rue moins
de violence intrafamiliale moins de
violence contre les femmes moins de
cambriolages moins d'homicides vous
pouvez le garantir et bien sûr que oui
parce que sinon je me présenterai pas
pour être présidente de la République
voyez je pensais des jeux considère
qu'avec le pouvoir d'achat la sécurité
est des éléments absolument essentiels
et une demande parfaitement légitime
d'ailleurs des Français là la situation
du pays
et vraiment très mauvaise j'essaye de
pas utiliser des adjectifs
trop
catastrophiste et pourtant on pourrait
parce que on est confronté à une vraie
barbarie on est confronté un vrai en
sauvagement on est confronté à
partout je vais moi partout y compris
dans la dans la campagne la plus
profonde partout j'ai des gens qui me
disent on en peut plus
on est cerné par l'insécurité cerner
dans les villes cernées dans les
campagnes cernées dans les transports
cette situation est vraiment très
inquiétante et il faut y apporter des
réponses et des réponses très fermes
l'effet se déroule absolument partout
maintenant on siphonne les les
comment dire les voitures pour voler
l'essence on pile les chantiers on pile
les exploitations agricoles on vole les
les bêtes sur pied d'ailleurs même
parfois les récoltes l'engrais
maintenant c'est l'engrais vol toi dès
quelque chose à la moindre valeur dans
notre pays et bien les gens tremblent
que on leur retire qu'on
qu'on leur vole ou qu'on les brutalise
et ça c'est insupportable donc il faut
faire deux choses prioritairement
d'abord il faut
régler le problème de l'immigration
anarchique et massive car je le dis très
clairement l'immigration anarchique et
massive contribue à l'aggravation de
l'insécurité dans notre pays c'est la
raison pour laquelle je vais proposer un
référendum aux Français nous aurons
sûrement l'occasion de parler tout à
l'heure qui vise à changer radicalement
la politique d'immigration pour que
enfin simplement les Français décident
qui vient qui se maintient et qui doit
partir et qu'on fasse respecter la loi
notamment en renvoyant chez eux non
seulement les clandestins mais également
évidemment les délinquants et les
criminels et puis il faut
de la fermeté
bien sûr il faut de la prévention mais
il faut aussi de la fermeté et dans le
domaine de la justice les Français ont
le sentiment que c'est devenu le laxisme
le plus total le laxisme par manque de
moyens bien souvent il faut le dire
il faut donc réarmer les policiers
moralement d'abord et je suis vous le
savez pour la présomption de légitime
des fonds je pense qu'il faut à nouveau
leur faire confiance ils ont beaucoup
souffert de du mépris de votre
gouvernement ils ont beaucoup souffert
de leur mise en cause permanente ils ont
beaucoup souffert des doutes que vous
avez exprimé à leur égard et donc il
faut les réarmée moralement il faut
d'abord les aimer après tout pourquoi
pas aussi les aimer leur faire confiance
leur rappeler rappeler à l'ensemble des
Français que c'est grâce à eux que on
peut vivre en sécurité et puis il faut
être beaucoup plus dur sur les peines il
faut la certitude de la peine il faut
arrêter avec les aménagements de peine
aujourd'hui grâce à Monsieur
Dupont-Moretti et Madame Taubira avant
lui avant un an de prison ferme avant un
an et bien vous
avez des peines aménagées bon excusez
moi mais les aménagements de peine moi
j'ai été avocat c'est considéré par les
délinquants comme l'impunité totale
voilà
la peine c'est porter un bracelet aller
au commissariat pour pointer etc c'est
comme si on ne faisait rien donc moi je
crois que il faut revenir à la certitude
de la peine je sais mieux de mettre une
petite peine de 5 jours ou de 15 jours
qu'on effectue plutôt qu'une peine d'un
mois d'un an qu'on effectue pas voilà ce
que je pense et d'ailleurs les Pays-Bas
me donne raison car ils font cela et
c'est très efficace je pense que il faut
à tout prix que l'on s'attaque aux
attentes à l'intégrité physique on ne
peut plus accepter dans notre pays que
pour un oui ou pour un non on vous
blesse ou vous violente on vous saute
sur la tête ou on cherche à vous
assassiner ça ça n'est plus possible et
c'est pour ça que de la manière la plus
claire qui soit je veux que l'on stoppe
les les aménagements de peine pour
toutes les peines de plus de 6 mois
ferme quand il s'agit d'intégrité
physique mais tout ça n'est possible et
j'en termine mais j'ai beaucoup d'autres
choses à dire bien sûr sur le sujet mais
tout ça n'est possible que si évidemment
on construit des places de prison car il
est évident que beaucoup de magistrats
ne peuvent pas
décréter une peine dont il sa
pertinemment qu'elle ne sera pas
appliquée et ça c'est quelque chose
encore une fois de très nocif donc il
faut construire des peines de des places
de prison et notamment en l'espèce 25000
qui sont absolument nécessaires bien
marine vous avez presque 5 minutes
d'avance manuel Macron je vous propose
même question Emmanuel Macron Camarine
Le Pen en 2027 vous engagez-vous si vous
êtes réélu à ce qu'il y ait moins de
violence moins de délinquance moins de
criminalité dans ce pays
oui vous noterez quand même que c'est
assez difficile de répondre NON à votre
question telle qu'elle est formulée et
pour Madame Le Pen comme pour moi et
c'est évident que je m'y engage et parce
que les moyens
et quel moyen allez-vous déployer pour
ce faire j'y viens rassurez-vous d'abord
parce qu'on s'en est donné les moyens et
nous débattons aujourd'hui
moi j'ai aussi en mémoire ce qui s'est
passé il y a 5 ans le moment où nous
débattons dans un autre format c'était
avant le premier tour et policier
tombait Xavier juger cette période à
dépenser à nos policiers c'est d'y
penser chaque jour et c'est pas les
abandonner dès qu'il y a un coup de
grisou Madame Le Pen comme vous l'avez
fait quelques jours en parlant des
policiers de Monsieur Darmanin quand il
y avait un problème dans un de vos
événements vous savez ça suppose parce
que moi j'ai le sens du commandement en
effet vous êtes chaque jour mais vous
savez
postes de policiers de gendarmes ont été
créés pourquoi parce que on fait pas de
la sécurité avec des mots avec des
mentons serrés avec des postures on le
fait avec des moyens et donc on a créé
10 000 postes de policiers de gendarmes
ils sont maintenant sur le terrain les
sorties d'écoles se sont achevées il y a
quelques mois et à côté de ça on a
augmenté les moyens de la justice
de 30% ces deux dernières années
fameux 9000 magistrats que vous
proposiez la dernière fois
nous y sommes donc les moyens sont là ce
qui fait qu'il y a d'ailleurs des
résultats puisque la délinquance sur les
biens en particulier a fortement diminué
et les chiffres sont aussi là qui le
fruit de l'implication de nos policiers
nos gendarmes nos services de
renseignement des résultats aussi sur la
lutte contre le terrorisme et je veux
saluer ce qui a fait le gouvernement ce
qu'on fait l'ensemble des services avec
plus d'une trentaine d'attentats des
jouets et le fait que vous n'en ayez pas
du tout parlé montre pas que ce sujet
s'était clipsé mais que c'est un sujet
sur lequel nous avons fortement augmenté
les moyens l'organisation collective moi
il y a quatre choses si je devais les
sortir si je puis dire les isoler sur
lesquels je veux pouvoir agir fort de ce
de ce que j'ai fait durant ces cinq
années de ce que nous avons bâti le
premier ce sont les féminicides
si les chiffres des violences aux
personnes augmentent c'est à plus de 80%
. les violences intrafamiliales
parce qu'il y a eu une fin d'omerta je
suis fier de ça je l'avais d'ailleurs
évoqué c'était du tout monsieur
par des de manière gratuite il y a une
agression toutes les 44 secondes
c'est
ce sont des victimes qui sont aussi
louables que celle que vous avez tout à
l'heure
qu'à 80% les chiffres qu'il y a derrière
ces augmentations ce sont ces violences
intrafamiliales et c'est féminicides ça
n'enlève pas les autres Madame Le Pen
toutes ces vies sont importantes et tout
ce que subissent nos compatriotes est
important mais ne relativisez pas ce que
je suis en train de relativement
que les résultats sont pas très bons et
donc non mais on a parce que la parole
se libérer parce qu'on a formé des
policiers des gendarmes qui avant ne
prenaient pas et moi je ferai pas de
politique qui consiste à cacher la
poussière sur le tapis parce que ce qui
était avant de la main courante
maintenant et de la prise de plainte
parce qu'on a investi parce que les
associations ont fait un travail
formidable avec nous parce qu'on a mis
en place des numéros 24 heures sur 24
parce qu'on a justement commencé cette
lutte il faut aller au bout très
fortement
avec notre police avec notre justice on
a mis en place les bracelets sont pas
encore tous donné il faut aller beaucoup
plus loin on a mis en place des mesures
pour isoler et éloigner les conjoints
violents donc ça pour moi c'est une
priorité la deuxième c'est dans le la
ruralité
grâce aux moyens que nous avons dégagé
et aussi aux réformes que nous avons
fait sur en particulier le temps de
travail et la loi d'orientation et de
programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur qui est prête
on pourra créer 200 brigades de
gendarmerie dans nos campagnes et face à
cette violence du quotidien ce retour de
l'insécurité ces brigades auront un rôle
de stabilisation lutte contre les
stupéfiants qui doit demeurer une
priorité qu'on a lancé renforcé depuis
2018 mais aussi sur les insécurités du
quotidien la troisième chose dont vous
n'avez pas du tout parlé mais qui va
être le
malgré tout et qu'il est déjà et qu'il
est déjà pour nos compatriotes c'est le
cyber parce que vous savez beaucoup des
risques et de l'insécurité va être les
attaques cyber contre les hôpitaux
contre les services publics les
randonneurs privés
les terroristes les agresseurs utilisent
et utiliseront de plus en plus ses
moyens c'est pourquoi je veux créer le
cadre législatif pour le faire mais
aussi les moyens en mettant en place
1500 cyber patrouilleurs qui vont
permettre justement d'abord de répondre
très vite de protéger on sait le faire
parce qu'on a une agence nationale mais
il faut déployer les moyens c'est une
vraie révolution en terme de sécurité et
puis le dernier point c'est la justice
évidemment tout ça ne marche pas s'il y
a pas de défectivité de la peine moi je
ne partage pas vos points sur les très
courtes peines parce que je pense que
mettre un délinquant léger dans une
prison où il va fréquenter des
délinquants plus lourds c'est une
absurdité je pense qu'il faut à ce
moment là avoir justement des moyens
pour les mineurs on a fait une réforme
de l'ordonnance qui permet d'injustice
qui passe beaucoup plus vite faut leur
permettre d'avoir soit de la rétention
dans un environnement militaire ce qui
est une de mes propositions soit des
travaux d'intérêt généraux sous contrôle
pour en particulier c'est plus petit
délinquant mais ils n'ont pas ces deux
jours ou trois jours je vous assure
quand on regarde les trajectoires c'est
très peu efficace bien mais surtout faut
donner les moyens à la justice d'agir de
passer et donc au-delà des 30% qu'on a
déjà fait de ces créations de poste je
veux aller au bout de ces états généraux
de la justice que nous avons lancé qui
permettront organiser beaucoup de choses
de dégager du temps pour nos magistrats
et nos personnels de justice mais je
veux d'ores et déjà créer 8500 personnes
de justice
magistratifié personnel qui perd
administratif qui vont permettre
d'alléger la charge de nos magistrats et
de répondre beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
vite parce que un des points sur les
situations du quotidien qui est
insupportable pour nos compatriotes
c'est quand il y a de sentiments une
réalité d'impunité quand la décision de
justice n'est pas assez rapide on a
commencé à le faire avec les délégués du
procureur sur le terrain avec cette
justice de proximité il faut qu'on aille
beaucoup plus vite et beaucoup plus fort
par se réinvestissement vous avez
développé l'un et l'autre véritablement
vos programmes vous me regardez Marine
Le Pen vous avez donné vos propositions
vous avez eu cinq minutes chacun pour
développer parce que l'ensemble
c'est un peu court quand même on a une
question si vous le voulez bien sur la
laïcité puisque le temps presse
je serai très respectueux à votre égard
vous ça ne se voit pas moi j'ai peur que
ça se voit beaucoup madame il y a une
question sur on n'a pas parlé la laïcité
si vous le voulez bien c'est une
question importante c'est une question
importante c'est un point important de
vos programmes et de votre programme
notamment Marine Le Pen question à tous
les deux même chose question simple si
vous êtes élu ou réélu pour vous
changerez-vous les règles qui régissent
le port des signes religieux dans
l'espace public par exemple une femme
pourra-t-elle porter le voile dans la
rue ou dans le métro où ce sera interdit
vous avez la parole permet d'abord
permettez-moi quand même de d'essayer de
sortir de de sujets qui
ont passionné les médias dans les
derniers jours mais qui sont arrêtés ne
sont qu'une partie d'un tout moi ce que
je souhaite faire c'est lutter contre
l'islamisme voilà parce que
contrairement à ce que vous dites j'ai
pas oublié qu'il y a du terrorisme j'ai
pas oublié qu'il y a des islamistes j'ai
pas oublié
je pense que le risque terroriste c'est
toujours extrêmement présent et
d'ailleurs pas eu toute une série
d'attentats terroristes je suis désolé
de le dire aussi alors qui ont été
attentats terroristes individuels mais
il n'en demanda pas moins que ça a été
des attentats terroristes donc il y a un
islamisme dans notre pays qui dont je
pense que la politique que vous avez
menée contre lui n'est pas efficace et
je pense qu'il faut mettre en œuvre une
loi de lutte contre l'idéologie
islamiste donc je m'entends je le répète
je ne lutte pas contre une religion je
ne lutte pas contre l'islam qui est une
religion qui a toute sa place il y a
aucun problème je lutte contre
l'idéologie islamiste qui est une
idéologie qui s'attaque au fondement de
notre République qui s'attaque à
l'égalité homme-femmes qui s'attaquent à
la laïcité qui s'attaque à la démocratie
qui s'attaque et qui cherche à imposer
en réalité une loi religieuse qui
s'appelle la charia je pense que cette
islamisme doit être combattue par une
république fière d'elle-même et pas une
république honteuse
et par exemple je note que il y a
4500 étrangers qui sont inscrits au
fichier du FF du SFR
ffprt pardon je vais y arriver et qui
est donc le fichier de qui réunit les
radicalisés qui évidemment trouble
l'ordre public cela devrait être expulsé
il devrait être expulsé alors le
gouvernement expulsé clandestin inscrit
sur le même fichier mais pas les
étrangers inscrits sur ce fichier je
pense que il faut les expulser parce
qu'il faut protéger évidemment nos
compatriotes il faut fermer les 570
mosquées radicales il ne faut pas se
contenter d'une Charte de la laïcité qui
a été mise en œuvre mais dont ceux qui
refusent de la signer et bien on peut
continuer à oeuvrer peuvent continuer à
recruter peuvent continuer à prêcher
peuvent continuer à chercher des
financements je trouve que nous ne
sommes pas assez ferme sur ce sujet
parce que le
[Musique]
deux voiles dans l'espace public
restez-vous au statu quo présent ou
changerez-vous la loi d'abord je vous
écoute vous faites avec beaucoup de
clarté démonstration mais ce qui est
inquiétant dans votre démonstration
c'est le chemin qu'elle emprunte
d'une question sur le voile vous êtes
passé au terrorisme pour revenir à
l'islamisme et pour aller aux étrangers
et vous créez un système d'équivalence
par votre cheminement qui confond tous
les problèmes et qui les entretient
la question du vol c'est la question
d'une religion un signe extérieur
religieux
la question du foulard plus exactement
d'ailleurs moi je suis pour la loi de
1905 c'est notre République la
République et laïque la laïcité ce n'est
pas combattre une religion et donc avec
moi il n'y aura pas l'interdiction ni du
foulard ni de la kippa ni de quelques
signes religieux dans l'espace public
parce que le principe d'égalité fait que
si vous rentrez dans cette logique
Madame Le Pen vous interdirez tous les
signaux religieux dans l'espace public
et pas simplement le foulard vous n'avez
pas du mal à non mais j'ai lu la
Constitution française vous m'excuserez
de cela et elle est
les lois vous prendrez même si vous
étiez élu ce que je ne souhaite pas
évidemment elle devra en respecter une
constitution bon et donc notre
Constitution nos textes fondamentaux
c'est cela c'est la laïcité la laïcité
c'est un principe de liberté
et donc à l'école il n'y a pas de voile
parce qu'on forme des consciences il y a
aucun signe religieux d'ailleurs c'est
pas que le foulard tous les signes
religieux sont proscrits puisqu'on forme
des consciences des citoyens en devenir
dans les services publics il y a une
neutralité des services publics elle est
absolue par contre dans la cité
vous allez créer la guerre civile si
vous faites ça je vous le dis en toute
sincérité parce que ça veut dire que
vous vous attaquez de ce que vous dites
c'est très grave parce que ce que vous
proposez
un certain nombre de personnes qui
refuseraient d'appliquer la loi je suis
en train de vous dire que la France
patrie des Lumières de l'universel
serait le premier pays au monde à
interdire les signes religieux dans
l'espace public le premier pays au monde
c'est ça ce que vous proposez Sana aucun
sens ça n'est pas le respect de nos
valeurs ce sera même un faisable combien
de policiers le premier pays au monde à
mettre en place beaucoup de lois vous
savez de liberté de tolérance là vous
proposez
parce que vous confondez deux choses
vous avez oublié sur le voile il y a
quelques années justement je suis fidèle
à tout ce que j'ai toujours voulu dire
défendu d'ailleurs j'aurais passé des
lois si je pensais le contraire mais
Madame Le Pen c'est pas la France de
l'universalisme ce que vous proposez
combien de policiers de gendarmes iront
courir après un voile une qui passe une
religieux
c'était temporaire et les gens ont été
rigoureux mais vous n'êtes ce n'est pas
sérieux donc ça c'est mon premier point
sur le sur le foulard laïcité je pense
nous avons incontestablement une diverge
nous avons très clairement une
divergence et je pense que ce que vous
proposez
est une trahison ce qui est l'esprit
français et la République moi je crois
que c'est au contraire la défense la
République il y a une deuxième chose
parce que vous avez dit il y a le combat
contre l'islamisme faut pas confondre
les deux on a des millions de nos
compatriotes dans la religion et l'islam
j'ai dit au début de mon propos mais ils
veulent vivre très tranquillement je
l'ai dit ils veulent pouvoir latify ben
laten par exemple qui a perdu son fils
tomber sous un acte terroriste que nous
voyons tous avec émotion avec son son
foulard vous voulez lui arracher son
foulardez de manière très concrète donc
ce que je dis juste c'est que vous êtes
en train de pousser des millions de nos
compatriotes de par leur religion hors
de l'espace public la deuxième chose
l'islamisme qui n'est pas l'islam
l'islamisme je l'ai combattu comme aucun
président avant moi et aucun
gouvernement autorité auparavant par une
loi que vous n'avez pas voté elle non
plus d'autres que votre sensibilité le
courage de la voté pour la réaffirmation
des principes de la République elle a
permis de faire quoi ce qu'on ne pouvait
pas faire jusque là Madame Le Pen ne
dites pas de mais rien monsieur je vous
en prie ne dites pas de bêtises non nous
avons fermé plusieurs plusieurs
associations qui ne respectaient pas la
loi de la République les unes parce
qu'elles prenait justement la charia
l'anonégalité entre les femmes et les
hommes la sortie de la République les
autres parce qu'elle prenait un
nationalisme étrangers sur notre console
d'autres encore parce qu'elles étaient
d'extrême droite et qu'elles ne
proposait de ne pas respecter la
République donc on a fermé des
associations on les a dissoutes la
deuxième chose vous avez encore donné
des chiffres exorbitants pour faire peur
aux gens sur 10.600 lieux de culte
il y en a 99 qui étaient suspectés de
justement de séparatisme tous ont été
mis sous surveillance nos préfets et nos
services font un travail extraordinaire
je le dis ici avec beaucoup de
reconnaissance 23 ont été fermés Grâce à
cette loi 23 36 ont changé et sont sous
contrôle toutes les autres sont en cours
d'examen avant cette loi on ne pouvait
pas fermer une telle structure même si
vous aviez un imam qui disait les pires
choses on ne pouvait les fermer qu'avec
des critères sanitaires la loi permet de
le faire cette loi a permis de mettre
fin à un système ou des gens qui étaient
payés par des puissances étrangères pour
enseigner sur notre sol
pouvez le faire en langue étrangère sans
sans le contrôle de l'éducation
nationale nous avons mis fin un système
on peut être technique on les appelait
celui des Zelko donc nous avons avancé
mais en nous battant contre l'islamisme
radical celui qui sépare de la
République mais en ayant mais en nous
confondons pas l'islam et l'islamisme
radical vous avez 3 minutes pour
répondre parce que viennent directement
le sens de ma loi et encore une fois
merci d'ailleurs de me permettre de
rappeler à aux musulmans que je ne
m'aime pas de guerre contre leur
religion en aucun cas
dans un certain nombre de cas par
ailleurs
ils sont eux-mêmes des victimes des
islamistes en réalité qui subissent dans
leur quartier parce que les caïdes qui
s'organisent dans un certain nombre de
quartiers sont bien souvent tenus par
les islamistes et ils sont toujours là
et ces quartiers sont toujours là et des
gens en souffrent encore et moi je
considère que c'est au contraire
défendre la République défendre
l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
défendre la la que de s'opposer à ces
islamistes par l'intermédiaire d'une loi
qui les vise et qui ne vise que au moins
les choses seront extrêmement claires
mais les chiffres que je donne sont
hélas vrai et c'est les chiffres de la
desserté donc moi je veux bien qu'il
soit faux mais lorsque on dit qu'il y a
570 mosquées radicales il y a 570
mosquées radicales votre loi n'a servi à
rien vous avez mis en place une charte
de la laïcité je viens de vous dire les
résultats
ceux qui n'ont pas les mères font un
travail formidables de la laïcité
qu'est-ce qui leur est arrivé on leur
enlève les subventions madame le
penal pour le coup j'aimerais bien voir
ça parce que en l'occurrence j'ai
vérifié tout ça de très près il ne leur
est absolument rien arrivé voilà rien
rien
et d'ailleurs je vais vous dire il
devrait même plus être là s'ils sont
étrangers devrait être chez eux mais il
devrait être expulsés
sur notre territoire se permet de ne pas
signer ce que la République lui demande
il devrait être envoyé chez lui mais
c'est vrai qu'on ne renvoie à personne
ça faut être honnête que ça c'est
quelque chose c'est un invariant de
votre quinquennat vous n'avez absolument
renvoyé personne mais on parle très
souvent d'association française
vous avez le plus mauvais bilan je crois
des 15 dernières années
on parle de religion
c'est une religion non mais là vous me
parlez de religion vous me parlez
d'idéologie qui utilise une religion en
France idéologie c'est pas une religion
c'est vous qui avez fait la confusion
comme je le pointais tout à l'heure
parce que vous ne pouvez pas expliquer
qu'une loi qui interdit le voile dans
l'espace public est une voie contre
l'islamisme radicale et bien si
peut-être monsieur Macron met dans tous
les pays musulmans ou législamistes ont
gagné ils ont volé les femmes voilà donc
ça ça devrait déjà vous interpeller et
d'ailleurs dans tous les pays où des
pays musulmans qui ont combattu les
islamistes quand ils ont gagné ils ont
dévoilé les femmes et ça c'est quelque
chose qui devrait vous interpeler mais
voilà alors je sais que vous avez
parfois convoqué des figures historiques
donc ça peut arriver d'avoir la langue
qu'il faut que vous abaissez pas à ça
demeurant c'est même pour Bourguiba en
Tunisie c'est faux non c'est vrai non
c'est faux il interdit à l'école comme
en France il interdit à l'école et vous
ne changerez pas la société beaucoup
plus ferme que vous sur ce sujet j'ai un
discours très fort nous avons passé des
lois ferme nous avons des résultats nos
mères le font avec nous mais vous ne
pouvez pas diviser la France et renvoyer
des millions de Français
l'immigration dont on a pas parlé et
c'est bien dommage parce qu'on parle de
l'immigration des binationaux des
étrangers des économies
Marine Le Pen donc moi ce que je
souhaite c'est présenté aux Français un
référendum sur l'immigration serait fait
un dôme sur l'immigration il a vocation
a changé les règles qui sont
actuellement en cours c'est vrai et il
comporte ce référendum que je ferai
voter si je suis élu des probablement le
le l'automne toute une série de
modification de révision de la
Constitution la Constitution c'est la
loi suprême que le peuple se donne et
par conséquent il n'y a je pense que le
peuple qui a le droit de la modifier et
dans cette loi il y aura enfin dans ce
référendum qui est un projet de loi en
lui-même que j'appelle d'ailleurs tous
les Français aller lire parce que il est
sur le site de ma campagne il y aura la
suppression l'expulsion des criminels et
des délinquants étrangers il y aura la
suppression du droit du sol parce que je
pense que la nationalité française série
tout se mérite on ne peut pas l'obtenir
de manière automatique il y aura la mise
en oeuvre de la priorité nationale au
logement et à l'emploi ça veut dire que
les Français seront pas exclusivement
mais prioritairement bénéficiaires de
l'accès au logement social et
accessoirement que les chefs
d'entreprise pourront donner une
priorité aux Français dans les embauches
qu'ils effectuent il y aura
l'interdiction de la régularisation des
clandestins que je pense que quand on
vient de manière illégale sur un
territoire et bien la seule chose à
faire c'est leur demander de retourner
chez eux et de demander l'autorisation
de venir il y aura la modification du
droit d'asile
c'est à dire que les demandes d'agiles
sont effectuées dans les consulats et
les ambassades de n'importe quel pays du
monde des ambassades de France bien sûr
de n'importe quel pays du monde parce
que là le problème que nous avons
actuellement c'est que nous avons
énormément de gens qui viennent qui
demandent d'asile et quand on leur
refuse et bien il reste quand même sur
le territoire puisqu'il n'y a que 10 %
d'exécution des obligations qui étaient
le territoire donc tout cela doit
profondément changer car l'immigration
est un problème qui fait dépenser
beaucoup d'énergie à notre société dans
beaucoup de domaines différents Emmanuel
Macron vous avez une grosse minute pour
dire vos propositions sur les migration
et répondre peut-être à Marine Le Pen
alors d'abord moi je veux distinguer
là aussi les choses entre elles l'asile
protégée par notre Constitution doit
continuer de protéger celles et ceux qui
fuient leur pays parce qu'il y a la
guerre parce qu'ils sont des combattants
de la liberté parce qu'il filippent et
soyons clairs et transparents avec nos
compatriotes nous aurons à accueillir
beaucoup d'ukrainien et du crayon
oui ils vont demander l'asile on fait ce
choix et donc je vais simplement dire
que quel que soit les changements que
vous voulez sauf à ce que vous vouliez
changer et revenir sur nos valeurs nous
aurons à le faire la deuxième chose
c'est la lutte contre l'immigration
clandestine vous reproche rien je dis
des choses je laisse je les distingue et
ensuite l'immigration économique dont on
a besoin et qu'il faut assumer on a des
étudiants on a des femmes et des hommes
qui viennent travailler dans notre pays
et qui aident notre pays de plus fort et
celle-ci elle est régulée avec des
titres de séjour faut qu'on puisse
continuer de la mener
et puis il y a l'immigration clandestine
la grande difficulté c'est que les
filières d'immigration clandestine
utilisent l'asile et dans beaucoup de
pays européens nous ont mis sous
pression ces dernières années très
fortement
maintenant par les pays de notre
frontière orientale que ces réseaux sont
organisés ces mafia qui utilisent la
misère ce sont des gens qui sont dans
des situations très grandes pauvreté de
grandes misères qui qui arrivent et donc
on doit réussir à mieux protéger nos
frontières la deuxième chose on doit
instruire beaucoup plus rapidement nous
avons mené une première réforme de
l'organisme qui est en charge de cette
instruction on a réduit les délais pas
assez la crise covid ne nous a pas aidés
faut bien le dire le Conseil d'État a
fait une série de propositions que je
veux pouvoir mettre en oeuvre pour
réduire drastiquement ces délais parce
que quand quelqu'un parce qu'il demande
l'asile mais 18 mois à avoir sa
procédure puis ils appellent c'est très
difficile de le raccompagner parce que
très souvent il a commencé à établir une
vie familiale normale il a commencé à
s'installer il est très difficile à
accompagner dans son pays d'origine il
faut que tout ça tienne en six mois
maximum donc changer nos règles ça c'est
ce que je propose
le troisième élément rapidement c'est
une politique plus efficace de retour
vers le pays d'origine parce qu'il
suffit pas de le dire la loi française
est quelques référendum que ce soit n'y
changeront rien c'est la coopération des
pays d'origine et pour ça il faut
conditionner notre politique de visa à
ses retours c'est ce que nous avons fait
avec plusieurs pays avec des résultats
sur plusieurs étrangers qui étaient
fichés au fsprt et avec un résultat qui
montre que cette politique est bonne
mais il faut discuter avec quelqu'un
parce que c'est même avec un référendum
vous ne raccompagnerez pas des gens dans
un pays qui n'est pas le vôtre
et cette politique
vous avez abord vous avez prononcé tout
à l'heure un Mollo de référendum que
vous lui organiser ça nous amène à notre
dernier thème il est très important
c'est celui des institutions et de la
gouvernance la France connaît ce n'est
pas nouveau et le phénomène c'est
semble-t-il aggraver une vraie crise de
défiance de confiance à l'égard des élus
de la politique et même des institutions
vous deux ces derniers jours ces 10
jours avaient prononcé des mots comme
référendum septennat proportionnelle et
Emmanuel Macron si vous êtes réélu
allez-vous avoir recours fréquemment
plus fréquemment au référendum
allez-vous instaurer la proportionnelle
et amener le septennat alors d'abord
nous venons de vivre un quinquennat un
peu particulier
je me dis parce que quasiment la moitié
du quinquennat s'est faite sous crise
profonde la pandémie en particulier et
donc j'entends les reproches qui sont
faits en disant vous n'avez pas fait de
référendum sous aucun canard je noterai
que plusieurs de mes prédécesseurs
n'ont pas fait de référendum sous leur
premier mandat parfois ils en ont fait